Okay, Sekunde, was hat Teams wieder mit meinem Mikrofon gemacht?
Nö, wieso, stimmt doch alles.
Mittlerweile bin ich schon so paranoid, was das einige Teams muss rumgestellt haben beim
Mikrofon.
Hat's auch meistens.
Es kommt ja nicht von ungefähr, es hat halt die Erfahrung gezeigt, Teams ändert immer
die Mikrofon-Settings.
Und ich hab bis heute nicht kapiert, wie man das Teams abgewöhnen kann.
Falls es überhaupt geht.
Das gehört wahrscheinlich zur authentischen Teams-Experience, dass das Mikrofon-Settings
verkackt.
Eine extra VM für Teams, ja, da musste dann aber das Mikrofon durch Pass Thruen irgendwie,
das ist auch nicht so sinnvoll.
Allez, jetzt kommt die
Wichtigeleverung.
So also ja es geht also du kannst Sounds relativ gut weiter reichen in VMWare aber
es lag teilweise also du hast bei gerade bei Output bei Input weiß ich es nicht also gerade
bei Output hast du durchaus gerne mal so eine halbe Sekunde Verzögerung was bisschen nervig
ist. Ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das auch noch in Kombination mit Pulse Audio noch mal
beschissen da ist, dass es dann irgendwie bei einer Sekunde lag. Man kann die Buffer Size in
den VM Settings ein bisschen verringern da muss man aber in das Text-File dafür hast du dann
teilweise geruckelt. Richtig pünktlich auf die Minute ja Leute soll ich sagen das war keine
Absicht wirklich keine Absicht ich sitze schon seit so irgendwie kurz nach acht hier vorm
Rechner und habe ein paar Sachen rum geklickt und habe ich gedacht so jetzt ist soweit und ich
habe nicht auf die Uhr geguckt das war wirklich Zufall dass es pünktlich um neun war. Ja Audio
unter Linux ist teilweise echt bisschen ein bisschen pains champ. Ich habe übrigens ein
ziemlich gutes Video letztens gesehen wo einer sich drüber ausgelassen hat über Windows,
Linux, Mac aus Entwicklersicht. Ich finde es war ziemlich gut auf den Punkt gebracht auch wenn ich
nicht alles so sehe aber im Großen und Ganzen muss ich sagen das trifft es ganz gut. Aber
was war das? Mal kurz gucken YouTube. Wie heißen die irgendwie so ne? Genau das Video war wirklich
nicht schlecht gucken wir uns vielleicht irgendwann. Hier das einzig wahre Betriebssystem zum
programmieren. Das da nicht jetzt aber das Video fand ich wirklich gute Zusammenfassung. Vielleicht
soll ich das nicht hier aufmachen sondern im YouTube Video Guck Tab weil ansonsten. Ups ich
habe das Video Pause gedrückt WTF. Microsoft oder in dem Fall eher Google. WTF ist das? Leute
wisst ihr was mir aufgefallen ist in YouTube Thumbnails? In dem Moment sieht man was. Kreise
beziehungsweise Kreise weniger. Pfeile sind wieder im Kommen. Guckt mal hier unten auch. Pfeile sind
gerade wieder im Trend. Ist mir in den letzten paar Wochen aufgefallen es gibt immer mehr Thumbnails
die wieder dieses Oldschool Pfeildings verwenden nur mit dem Unterschied dass es mittlerweile
gerne so gemacht wird so was weiß ich. Noob Pro und dann hast du hier in der Mitte das Bild
geteilt und dann links ein Bild von einem Noob und rechts ein Pfeil auf einem Pro oder sowas.
Das ist zurzeit echt wieder im Kommen. Guckt hier. Das gesplitterte Bild und dann mit dem Pfeil
das ist aktuell echt im Trend wieder. Warte mal Sound kommt.
Sound Control Panel. Ach nee Moment. In Settings oder im alten Control Panel? Oder wo oder hier?
Open Sound Settings? Da? Hier? Man weiß ja unter Windows nie. Altes okay. Ist natürlich
geil dass es mit einem Alten funktioniert hat. Okay Hardware und Sound. Sound. Der Mikrofon
Ausschlag hier und hier deckt sich sag mal nicht wirklich aber okay. Hier so und was
jetzt? Was? Advanced? Warte mal Mikrofon? Recording? Mikrofon? Advanced? Ja nee im Moment
das funktioniert das funktioniert. Aber dann hast du andere Probleme. Das hatte ich ich
bilde mir ein das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert und da gab es irgendwelche anderen Probleme.
Ach so ich habe den Haken übrigens entfernt. Aber das ändert das juckt Teams trotzdem
nicht daran meine Mikrofon Lautstärke lauter und leiser zu stellen.
Ludel. Unter Linux macht er ja gut unter Linux verstell nichts ungefragt einfach deine Sound
Settings unter Windows schon. Das macht nicht nur Teams aber Teams weil ich es öfters
verwenden muss ist das was mich am meisten nervt. Okay McDonalds Lunch in nee das gucken
wir uns nicht. Weil das ist nicht ich also ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch aussieht ich
habe aber die letzten fünf Jahre glaube ich kein McDonalds mehr gegessen und ich habe
auch nicht mehr so das Verlangen danach. Man muss nicht also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen
dass ich McDonalds irgendwie super eklig finde oder so sagen der Leute dann kann man da nicht
essen doch da kann man schon essen das schmeckt auch irgendwo essbar ja also das ist nicht
so dass man sagen muss das kann man kriegt man nicht runter aber ich habe da überhaupt
kein Bock mehr drauf früher war ich da richtig scharf drauf und es hat nichts damit zu tun
dass ich in letzter Zeit so viel abgenommen habe ich habe schon als ich als ich noch noch
pepo fettiger war habe ich schon kein McDonalds mehr gefuttert. McDonalds darf nicht gut sein
McDonalds also der Ziel von das Ziel von McDonalds ist ja nicht dass es gut ist die tun zwar
in der Werbung immer so als wäre das McDonalds nee das Ziel von McDonalds ist quasi das
was Mainstream Musik oder Mobile Games auch haben. Du sollst nicht irgendwie Leute begeistern
du sollst möglichst wenig Leute abschrecken also du sollst möglichst wenig Leute es eklig
finden lassen also wisst ihr wie ich meine es ist wahrscheinlich für McDonalds besser
dass als dass ein paar Leute sagen hm das ist richtig gut es ist besser wenn die meisten
Leute sagen ja das kann man essen also das wenn es 95% für 95% der Leute okay ist ist
besser wie wenn es die Hälfte der Leute super geil finden und die andere nicht mag so also
es funktioniert das darf gar nicht besser sein glaube ich. Ich finde es ja auch immer
überraschend dass bei McDonalds Chicken Chicken Nuggets oder so das da drauf steht mit echtem
Hähnchenfleisch und denke ich mir immer so wie gibt es die Option auch nicht mit echtem
Hähnchen Hähnchenfleisch und mit Fake veganische Chicken Nuggets oder so. Veganer Burger ist
ja einfach nur um den um die Veganer zu jebaiten ich weiß eh nicht warum man als Veganer zu
McDonalds gehen will. Ich will ja schon so nicht zu McDonalds gehen. I bought a Portable
Sega Dreamcast from AliExpress. Guck schon wieder Pfeil Leute ich sag euch dieser rote
Pfeil und am besten auch mit gesplittert das ist zurzeit wieder im Trend. Ich frag mich
halt so würde ohne den roten Pfeil niemand checken das dass er dieses Gerät hier meint
aber muss halt sagen mit dem roten Pfeil es sieht halt einfacher klickbar aus das stimmt
schon also nicht. Der macht es legit einfach auf und an. Made in China Pog. Das spricht
ja spricht ja schon für die immense Qualität wahrscheinlich. Hat jemand von euch in letzter
Zeit was bei AliExpress bestellt? Ich mache ja so ein bisschen einen Bogen um AliExpress
in letzter Zeit seitdem die Schiffe nicht mehr nach Shanghai rein und raus kommen. Weiß
gar nicht ob das noch so ist. Weiß ich wie die wie sind so wie sind eigentlich so die
Lieferzeiten gerade bei. Sind so die Lieferzeiten bei AliExpress gerade. Wartet mal kurz muss
mal kurz kurz checken. Damenbekleidung ja genau ich wollte was Message Pistole ach Massage
Pistole was die da einmal suchen. So also ich wollte schon immer irgendwie so ein Weep iPhone
Phone haben. So und versandt bis 1 Monat das ist das ist normal das war früher bei AliExpress
auch schon je nachdem wie du bestellt hast. Safer Shipping und Standard Shipping. Ja einen
Monat. Allerdings gab es halt oftmals bei AliExpress auch noch billiger. Also nicht
billiger was laber ich denn schneller. Also du konntest du konntest bei AliExpress quasi
fünf sechs verschiedene Versandvarianten früher auswählen. Wovon manche unsinnig teuer waren
80 Euro 80 80 Euro Versand oder so. Aber du konntest teilweise sowas wie EU Priority
Line oder EU Express Shipping oder sowas machen. Dann kam das innerhalb von einer Woche
an. Oder du hattest sogar die Möglichkeit das aus dem EU Warenlager zu bestellen das
war noch besser. Ja genau ja. Hey vielen Dank für den Sub 28 Monate. Leute ich muss unbedingt
mal die das Designer Grill fragen ob wir weitere Sub Kekse bekommen können. Weil den Gold
Keks mit Kette den haben ja die meisten die jetzt schon länger dabei sind schon. Das
muss noch ein bisschen Upgraded werden. Ja Gold Gold Kette mit mir fällt gar nichts ein
aber dafür hat man ja Creative Pfeiffer Designer den was einfällt. Ich kann jetzt ja auch nicht
sagen ich mach den Gold Keks mit Kette hinten hin weil dann beschweren sich die Leute die
den Gold Keks mit Kette schon haben dass sie den Gold Keks mit Kette nicht mehr haben.
Das ist wie wenn Games sagen so wie bei New World zum Beispiel du bist quasi im Endgame
machst Progression und dann sagen die beim Patch Ach ne Progression ist jetzt schwieriger
du kriegst dein Item jetzt doch nicht. So das kann ich ja nicht machen. Diamant Keks haben
wir schon. Diamant Keks haben wir schon. Wir haben normalen Keks wir haben Silber Keks
wir haben Diamant Keks und wir haben Gold Keks. Was mit roten Pfeilen. Ja man könnte
das Problem ist man muss also man kann dem Keks nix auf den Kopf setzen außer einen Stirnband
eventuell oder so aber das passt nicht wirklich weil das macht es kleiner. Wisst ihr wenn
hier oben jetzt wenn hier oben so ein Hut wäre wenn hier oben ein Hut wäre dann würde es
das ganze Seitenverhältnis von dem Bild von dem Bild Stonks Keks. Man könnte vielleicht
noch irgendwie hier in die Gold Kette 100 Dollar scheinen oder ein Euro scheinen oder so keine
Ahnung. Müsste man sich echt überlegen was man da machen kann. Ein Anhänger an die Kette
ja das könnte man tatsächlich machen mit den. Wisst ihr was das einfachste wäre wenn
man wirklich einfach einen Anhänger dran machen würde mit den Monaten oder so weil. Sonst
fällt mir halt nichts ein. Sonst müsste ich mir irgendwie für jedes für jede paar Monate
eine neue Keks überlegen was schwierig ist. Vielleicht lass ich auch einfach komplett
neue Sub Emotes also neue neue nicht Sub Emotes neue Subscription Batches machen die aber die
Kekse mit dem Gold passt schon finde ich schon nicht schlecht. Der Sonnenbrille ist das einzige
was mir auch schon eingefallen ist tatsächlich also Sonnenbrille habe ich mir aber das hat
auch glaube ich letztens der Chat vorgeschlagen. Sonnenbrille auf die Idee bin ich auch schon
gekommen. Ansonsten fällt mir da nicht mehr allzu viel ein. Das wird man hier auch halbwegs
darauf erkennen. Keine Ahnung das kann ich wieder zumachen. Übrigens Leute wisst ihr
was wir machen müssen in einem der Streams in nächster Zeit wir müssen Python lernen.
Was heißt lernen? Ich kann das ja halbwegs brauchbar so wenn es mal sein muss aber nicht
wirklich gut und mir ist aufgefallen in letzter Zeit dass ich öfters mal irgendwelchen kleinen
Skript Kram habe der zu nervig lange in Bash ist und zu ätzend in Bash ist und wo sich
aber nicht lohnt irgendein Dotnet Projekt zu machen und dann irgendwie einen 60 MB selfcontained
executable zu bauen oder so. Moin und deswegen müsste ich wahrscheinlich mal eine Runde
Python lernen in einem der nächsten Streams. Oder zumindest mal aufrischen. Übrigens richtig
cringe passt mal auf Twitter das muss ich euch zeigen. Richtig lost könnte man, wie
sagt man jetzt sagt man heute zu Telekom erleben. Pass mal auf ein richtig hyper cringe Tweet
von der Telekom letztens gesehen. Wusstet ihr dass heute nationaler pink Tag ist und dass
es spezielle feiertage für farben gibt also bei uns ist jeder tag magenta tag und jetzt
kommt der cringe jetzt kommt ultra cringe kommentiert mit einem Herz Emoji warum haben
die hier eigentlich nicht dieses pinke Herz genommen einfach nur ein Herz kommentiert
mit einem Herz Emoji wenn für euch auch jeder tag magenta tag ist. Und wollen wir mal gucken
wie viele Leute ein Herz ein Herz WTF alter Twitter Twitter nicht viele oder nicht viele
wahrscheinlich sind das Telekom Mitarbeiter sechs Leute sechs Leute haben. Warte mal
haben die haben die wirklich das müssen wir uns von Firefox angucken Firefox kann mehr
Emojis als Windows haben die wirklich nicht das pinke Herz verwendet die haben wirklich
nicht das pinke Herz verwendet Leute wartet mal seit wann verwendet Firefox ach nee das
ist das ist das ist das Twitter Emoji nee pass die haben wirklich nicht das pinke das
pinke Herz verwendet das verstehe ich nicht das der hätte man der hätte man wirklich
jetzt aber nee das das war zu advanced Social Media Zeug für die Telekom. Aber das war
nicht richtig cringe alter antwortet wenn für euch auch jeder tag ein magenta tag ist
man eigentlich wisst ihr ich hätte damit antworten müssen. Vielleicht war das der
Praktikant aus der Marketing Nein das war sicherlich nicht der Praktikant das war irgendjemand
der dafür wahrscheinlich mehr verdient als wir alle zusammen dafür dass er solche krassen
pfeilfertigen Marketing Posts macht. Das wird ja schlimmer ein highly paid professional war
das bestimmt sogar noch. Naja also was hat denn YouTube heute zu bieten? Ach wir müssen
uns wo wir gerade dabei sind zeigt mal ganz schnell. Wie siehts denn mit Battlefield spiele
ok die sind immer noch mies aber immerhin guckt mal Leute die sinken wieder nur langsam
also wir sind wahrscheinlich erst in einer Woche oder in zwei Wochen wieder auf fast null.
Der Vodafone Tag Leute ihr müsst mal Vodafone auf Twitter euch angucken die haben den ganzen
Tag glaube ich nichts besseres zu tun wie sich da mit der Telekom zu beefen ihr müsst
immer drauf achten also Leute die auf Twitter schreiben mein Internet zackt heute wieder
da kommt dann die Telekom an und was weiß ich irgendjemand schreibt auf Twitter at Vodafone
mein Internet ist heute wieder richtig unstable und antwortet auf einmal die Telekom wenn
das bei Vodafone so lange dauert wir können dir gerne ein Angebot machen smiley smiley
und dann antwortet Vodafone was drauf habt ihr denn nichts besseres zu tun rennen euch
die Kunden weg oder irgendwie sowas dann frag ich mich auch haben die nichts anderes zu tun
oder was dass sich die offiziellen Support Kanäle da von Telekom und Vodafone was macht
new world dieses game also ich habe schon viele games gesehen die sind gelounge und
dann in der bedeutungslosigkeit versunken was ich aber ehrlich gesagt noch nie gesehen
habe ist ein game was bei release knapp eine millionen spieler hatte und es geschafft hat
innerhalb von naja zwei monaten drei monaten 90 prozent seiner spieler zu verlieren das
habe ich noch im online wird wahrscheinlich immer noch bei was weiß ich 60k oder so rum
krebsen so wie das wobei weiß ich gar nicht ach so die meisten spielen die meisten überhaupt
über steam ja ich fand immer ungefähr ungefähr ähnlich viel ja man darf nicht vergessen
new world war ein mmo was kleinzeit hit detection hatte bei einem mmo das muss man sich mal
vorstellen und die haben wirklich gedacht das spiel ist ready ein mmo mit kleinzeit
hit detection ich ja sehr six head chat wahnsinnig six hat die dumme idee kann nur amazon kommen
generell die ganze entwicklung von new world ist einfach nur pains champ also hätten die
hätten halt mal ein paar leute nehmen sollen die ahnung von mmos haben
chef im freibad der bademeister jawoll wollte immer wissen was ein bademeister verdient
eigentlich kenne ich bademeister nur wenn sie nerven wenn sie dir irgendwie erzählen
du solltest was weiß ich da dich erst abtrocknen oder du sollst hier nicht so rum spritzen
im wasser gachibas oder du sollst nein nicht gachibas leute oder keine ahnung hier sollst
ich so viele sollst du so viele liegen blockieren oder sollst von der richtigen seite ins becken
oder ach keine ahnung jetzt eigentlich ich habe noch nie ein bademeister wirklich in
action gesehen dass er jemand retten musste aus dem aus dem becken
if you sleep near your pc eigentlich nicht mehr nein warum ist das so leise ich hab das
mega laut das ist einfach prokunder short wow geiler tipp die festplanung also ganz
ehrlich da würde ich erstmal die ganze rgb entfernen wenn ich daneben pennen würde
ich bin jetzt leise ja ganz bestimmt sehe ich sofort hier dran guck da
warte mal teams hat dran rumgestellt fällt mir gerade auf weil ich habe ich 69 habe ich
nur verguckt so also was schauen wir uns denn an kommen es gibt doch bestimmt irgendwas
was halbwegs wir lassen uns üblich leute der übliche level cap jeep warum habe ich
okay drei mal muss ich youtube jetzt auch nicht offen haben der übliche level cap jeep
bait wann würdest du dein nächstes pc upgrade vollziehen ich warte ich warte ja schon die
ganze zeit drauf und zwar entweder dass der kram verfügbar ist oder aber dass eine neue
nvidia grafikkarten generation rauskommt weil jetzt noch eine alte eine reisen 5000
generation kaufen ich weiß gar nicht wie die heißen es reisen 3 also aktuell reisen generation
und eine aktuelle nvidia grafikkarten generation will ich eigentlich nicht mehr kaufen aktuell
intel könnte man sich kaufen aber ich will eigentlich ich habe darauf gehofft ich habe
darauf gehofft dass vielleicht eine neue amd ich wollte nämlich unbedingt mal wieder seit
irgendwie gefühlt 20 jahren oder so wie dann amd rechner haben ja die 5000 dinger meine
ich so das sind die aktuell da will ich mir aber eigentlich keinen mehr kaufen achten
drei reisen vier wachen notebook ja bessere benahmung hätte man hätten ja auch nicht
einfallen können also ich hätte am liebsten ich hätte am liebsten dass nvidia irgendwie
4080 ti oder 4080 was auch immer rausbringt oder 4090 oder so für 30 trillionen euro
was das dann kosten wird weil grafikkarten sind halt nicht mehr so dass man sich einfach
kaufen kann das muss ja mal mindestens irgendwie eine leber oder niere kosten weil ansonsten
kannst du keine grafikkarte dir mehr leisten so und dann will ich irgendeine neue amd cpu
als die was taugt mir nicht intel aber auf jeden fall eine neue gpu generation von nvidia
ist mir egal solange die im desktop betrieb sich ruhig kühlen lassen was ja mittlerweile
kein problem ist du kannst ja im desktop betrieb in der regel die rechner so machen gerade
wenn relativ großen cpu kühler hast dass die quasi nicht hörbar sind mein höre ich
quasi so gut wie auch gar nicht jetzt und wisst ihr was das wichtigste ist wo kaum jemand
dran denkt wenn er denkt an silent rechner oder leise rechner das wichtigste ist neben
so sachen wie netzteil lüfter cpu lüfter lüfter grafikkarten lüfter wisst ihr was
das mit abstand wichtigste ist oder neben gehäuse lüfter wo die leute nicht dran denken das
ist ein staubfilter fürs gehäuse weil ansonsten ist es die längste zeit leise gewesen du
brauchst ein staubfilter wenn du keinen staubfilter im gehäuse hast dauert das ding ein halbes
jahr und es wird immer lauter einfach weil es sich halt zusetzt mit staub und dann muss
es mehr kühlen und mehr lüften und und alles staubfilter staubfilter ist das wichtigste
überhaupt wenn man will dass das lange zeit leise bleibt
ist das ist das ist das ein cpu lüfter vom namen her kann es noch sein ich habe keine
ahnung was von gehört oh shit ja naja mal gucken dann hole ich mir halt ein fettes netzteil
soll mir recht sein ich hatte ich dachte eigentlich die zeiten mit rechner mit 1000 watt netzteil
sind vorbei als hatte man früher so zu atlon xp zeiten da hast du riesen fette 800 900
watt netzteil oder sowas reingebaut weil die die dinger auch übelst übertaktet hast
also ich glaube ich habe mich nie mehr mehr hackermans gefühlt oder oder mehr technik
geek gefühlt an an meinem pc als zu zeiten von atlon xp und kurz davor was war das zeleron
d oder zeleron 800 oder so die den übertakten kondis von 800 auf irgendwie 1700 oder so
da kam ich mir vor wie der bauer bloß dass den bauer damals noch nicht gab wahrscheinlich
der aua naja 1000 watt netzteil heißt ja nicht dass dein rechner permanent 1000 watt verbraucht
das ist nur wenn er mal auch gerade in spitzen das verbraucht dass er dir nicht ausgeht im
desktop betrieb wird er wahrscheinlich weitere fast nix brauchen fast nichts übertrieben
aber wenig verbrauchen gerade im vergleich zu den rechner von früher die keine gescheiten
power safe modi hatten also auch cpu technisch das war ja normal dass dann cpu lüfter da
immer auf volle pulle lief und dann cp auch cpu auch immer volle pulle das ist ganz schön
viel eidl ich hätte jetzt gedacht eidl bist du vielleicht bei 30 40 watt oder so
aufgewacht zum aufwachen stream beste da ist plan for battlefield ok wir lassen uns jetzt
leute wir lassen uns level cap jebaiten zeig her massive level cap jebait also der plan der
plan von da ist für battlefield 2042 ist ganz einfach das habe ich schon 85.000 mal
gesagt die haben das schon aufgegeben das ist quasi schon geistig eingestellt damit
nur noch das mindeste gemacht the new general manager at dice opened up about battlefields
future call of duty warzone season 4 is here a live action jedi fallen order tv show might
be in the works and much like gut die cashen ja auch in allem rein was geht aufs qualitativ
gut wirds einmal dahingestellt on this weekend game the new general manager at dice shared
some details about the studio this week in a blog post in several interviews rebecca
kutas love letter to the players leute explained how this to the fans restructure due to 2042
explain that the majority of dices developers are still working on 2042 also seriously wenn
die mehrzahl der dice entwickler an 2042 arbeiten warum tut sich in diesem game nix das gibt
einfach nur die möglichkeit sie erzählen scheiße oder sie sind unfähig ich weiß nicht
was davon schlechter ist die real firms dices commitment to the game but didn't clarify
if support could carry on beyond the previously advertised four seasons of content so ein dummes
geschwätze immer game play experience and continue adding also von da ist sie also mentioned
that the studios focused on 2042 at the moment their aim is to turn dice into an fps development
powerhouse by 2025 das ist einfach so marketing bullshit da ist waren ein fps powerhouse da
ist hätte einfach nur aufhören müssen scheiße zu sein mit den letzten paar battlefields das
ist alles das ist einfach so leeres marketing bullshit alter das ist so wie wenn ea vor ein
paar jahren erzählt hat ea vielleicht könnt ihr euch vielleicht könnt ihr euch noch dran
erinnern ea hat ja vor ein paar jahren auch rausgehauen so nach dem motto jetzt wird sich
alles ändern ea ist ab jetzt eine player first company haben sie gesagt vor drei vier jahren
und was hat es jetzt genau gebracht
2042 player count has risen on all platforms since the launch ja aber es geht auch wieder
runter wir haben doch gerade geguckt in a better place now compared to natürlich ist es in
a better place es hat eine gescheite map im vergleich zu keiner ist geil so we'll have
to wait and see if dice can keep up the momentum season 4 for vanguard in warzone ich frag mich
ernsthaft wenn wirklich der großteil von da ist noch an battlefield aber gibt es noch
zwei weitere variant entweder da ist hat kaum noch mit arbeiter weil sie die alle rausgeschmissen
haben oder mich würde wirklich mal interessieren was machen die eigentlich den ganzen tag mieten
die die mieten wahrscheinlich die machen meetings zu was auch immer zum nächsten battlefield
ich habe kein schimmer ok warzone season 4 vielleicht gucke ich mir warzone noch mal
an ich habe meine zeit lang recht viel gespielt wenn modern warfare 2 rauskommt also zwei
des reboots 2022 also davon fange ich aber nicht wieder an
hier also guck mal die haben das gleiche gemacht wie in einer battlefield season nur mit dem
unterschied die brauchen da keine acht monate für und haben nebenbei auch nur die halbe map
überarbeitet einfach mal so nebenbei einfach mal so nebenbei die acht monate rumgemacht
hat season 4 both the t-800 into 1000 terminators from the terminator movie franchise will be
added they'll be part of a mid-season update as limited-time bundles in store the terminators
will join the other 80s action movie cosmetics like die hart rainbow which were added to warzone
last year according to star wars insider christian harloff a live action version of jedi fallen
order is in the works at disney so überhaupt gar nicht the developers of extraction shooter
hunt showdown have warned players who abuse a new glitch by rapidly changing the firing
mode of the lamat mark 2 revolver okay also wenn du möchtest dass die spieler einen glitch
nicht ausnutzen ist das mit abstand schlechteste was du machen kannst den spielern sagen sie
sollen den glitch nicht ausnutzen das einfachste mehr den glitch möglichst schnell zu fixen
dass ihn keiner mehr ausnutzen kann aber wenn du den leuten sagst bitte bemacht etwas nicht
du kannst davon ausgehen dass jetzt einfach 90 prozent der leute selbst die noch gar nicht
von dem von der existenz dieses glitches wussten es jetzt machen werden vielleicht wissen sie
auch nichts wie man fixen soll ja gunn exhibits an unintentional power boost that gives the user a
huge advantage against other players the devs at crytech have commented on the issue stating that
they're aware of one of them how does crytech deal with support do they know what they're doing
it's honest i have no idea i'm not asking this because i want to know after the auto h0 everything is
shit but i just want to know if they get bugged i mean we looked at bell a lot before but they
don't get bugged how does hunt showdown look like do they get bugged
the problem and actively working to resolve it they also noted that the balance changes exploit fixes will be taken
against players who abuse the glitch yeah yeah ist klar ist klar actions against 90 prozent der
spieler werden diesen glitch verwenden wollen die 90 prozent ihrer player base band oder was
but it might be a full-on ban ja ganz bestimmt hat ein new anti-fraud system to combat in-game
items from being sold by third parties the system aims to catch accounts trying to sell items to
other players online these items may give users an unfair advantage that das geht ja nicht wenn
schon wenn schon muss ea den kram verkaufen it's built upon the current systems in games like fifa
and apex legends those games es kann ja nicht sein dass du zum china chinesen shop gehst um
dir vorteile zu kaufen du sollst wenn schon zu ea gehen dir vorteile zu kaufen ist ja klar oder
die hat measures in place to detect accounts that have more in-game currency or items than they
should the new patent tracks mich hat unter dem diablo video einer folgedist hat geschrieben
max ich wäre mit dran schuld dass es so gekommen ist mit diablo immortal und wisst ihr warum weil
ich damals in diablo 2 items auf ebay verkauft habe feels batman also jetzt wisst ihr jetzt wisst ihr
wen ihr halten müsst für diablo immortal mich stress stuff ea school seems to be tracking down
the players and third parties distributing the in-game items according to leaker tom henderson sony
will be hosting another state of play showcase next week it's rumored that new hardware will
be revealed this includes a new pro controller alongside three new headsets the headsets will
be part of sony's new in-zone gaming brand and be called the h9 h7 and h3 all three will feature
spatial audio however only the h7 and h9 will be a wireless they'll resemble the playstation 5 plus
headset but with a moment sound aus dem controller oder habe ich das jetzt gerade falsch verstanden
improved audio and build quality online rumors suggest a new stronger version of valve steam deck
ist on the way it's believed that the steam deck to will adopt amd's new zen for a noise steam deck
für das das erste ist auch kaum verfügbar gewesen our dna3 architectures this means it'll boast
four cores and eight threads making it 20% faster than the current version keep in mind that this
is unconfirmed for now and it's unlikely that a sequel console will launch soon after the steam
decks recent launch valve are also working on a new standalone vr headset codenamed the decker it
utilizes similar hardware to the steam deck to power desktop class vr experiences without needing
to be how cool is the people who have now bought a steam deck if there is now the next steam deck
I think it sells very well if there is no official announcement regarding the decker yet when I'm sure
that there will be a real game that I've wanted to play for years, but I'm always afraid that
you won't get in there right when you get in so late because it's just that in complex games
so if you get in there later you will be the first 100 hours after the motto because you have no idea
what you're doing means as a new faction with unique weapons a new map called the black coast
people people so if that actually reminds you of kark island then I don't know that's original
kark island the starting zone let's be honest that's 1 to 1 kark island but probably the
lower part of this ship modeled after real life role models and accordingly it looks the same
ja hat mal kark island rush
ist Defender der Kacknoob. Ich will ein Attacker Video haben, please. Attacker, Mensch, Attacker.
Ja, wunderbar, das ist er. Hier, guckt, guckt, seht ihr das im Hintergrund? Guckt euch das an,
das ist original. Alter Heli, Mann. Kann da irgendeiner normal starten? Nope. Die haben alle
keinen Bock im Hangar zu starten. Aber man hat's eben gesehen im Hintergrund. Also man hat's hier
eben im Hintergrund gesehen, guckt mal. Das ist original, der gleiche Hangar hier. Wenn man es
überhaupt Hangar... Spielt jemand von euch Squad? Und würde sagen, man kann da noch einsteigen.
In a recent hotfix. According to... Muss man ist Voice Chat Pflicht?
To skateboard legend Tony Hawk, remasters of Pro Skater 3 and 4 have been canceled by Blizzard
Entertainment. Earlier in the week Hawk commented on the remasters during a Twitch stream. He
stated that the original plan was to remaster the first two games followed by the third and
fourth. However, that plan went out the window when the studio responsible was moved to a support
role for other studios by parent company Activision Blizzard. Fans of the series are
unsurprisingly disappointed, especially after the remasters for the first two games were received
so well. Creative Assembly, the studio behind Total War and Alien Isolation announced that
they're working on a new sci-fi multiplayer FPS called Hyenas. Five teams of three are pitted
against each other to loot space malls known as plunder ships. Each team must escape the
area with the most loot. The devs have promised endless gameplay opportunities, quick movement
and lethal combat. The game also features zero G zones where teams will fight each other.
It'll launch on past and present generation consoles and PC sometime next year.
The annual gaming event Gamescom is still scheduled to go ahead this summer. However,
several notable publishers have publicly pulled out of the lineup. A spokesperson from Sony
confirmed that this week they would not be making an appearance at the show.
Will be opting to showcase their new content through the state of play event.
Ich weiß nicht, es sah jetzt nicht so aus, so nachdem man so, boah krass hier, sieht aus als fühlt sich das richtig gut an zu spielen, weiß nicht so, einfach nach nix.
Warte, damit ich mich das schon angucke.
Und das ist halt nix, das sieht einfach langweilig aus.
Man sieht welche Engine verwendet wurde, nee ich sehe das nicht, ich würde mal auf Fallout tippen, aber das kann ja eigentlich nicht sein, weil sie haben es mit Fallout 4 schon verkackt damals, irgendwas technisch halbwegs aktuelles rauszubringen.
Und ich bezweifle, dass das jetzt nochmal, dass das jetzt nochmal funst.
Warum macht das, warum macht das das Skateboard kaputt, warum hat das das Skateboard kaputt gemacht?
Alter was ist mit den Leuten los, wie nah willst du die Kamera dann noch ans Gesicht machen?
Das wird was, ich sag's euch ja, das wird was, okay sie haben, sie haben einen obvious, aber cleveren Schachzug gemacht, das Spiel wird free to play, das hätten die schon längst machen müssen,
aber das könnte dem Spiel tatsächlich was bringen, also free to play ist das einzige was ich mir vorstellen könnte, das dazu führt, dass Overwatch 2 langfristig Spiele hat und einen,
man kann jetzt nicht sagen erfolgt wird, weil Overwatch 1 war auch ein Erfolg, das muss man ganz klar sagen, es haben Millionen gekauft, es haben Millionen gespielt,
Man kann jetzt nicht sagen erfolgt wird, weil Overwatch 1 war auch ein Erfolg, das muss
man ganz klar sagen.
Es haben Millionen gekauft, es haben Millionen gespielt, aber es war halt einfach Langzeitsupport
technisch und gerade diese typische Blizzard Patch Politik war halt richtig für'n Arsch.
Excellent, jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Wir haben uns wieder LevelCapture baiten lassen, Cloudflare had another Outage, ja das weiß
ich, das interessiert mich aber nicht.
Bleeding Stack Technology, das neue YouTube der EU, da hab ich mir auch gedacht, Weirdchamp,
ich wusste gar nicht, dass YouTube ein, nein, nein, nein, dass die EU ein YouTube plant
und mal ganz davon abgesehen, geht man wirklich davon aus, dass so ein Technikprojekt erfolgreich
werden könnte?
Also mir fällt das schwer zu glauben, nachdem ich mir andere Dinger so angucke.
So, selbst IT-Projekte auf Deutschland-Ebene kriegen wir nicht gescheit hin, ich weiß
nicht, ob wir IT-Projekte auf EU-Ebene gescheit hinbekommen.
Ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen, dass das irgendjemand verwendet hat.
Ist nicht für die Allgemeiner nur für Pressesachen, ja dann ist es ja noch langweiliger.
Ok, zeig mal her.
Es ist die Exodia eines jeden Kritisierten und vor etwa drei Jahren noch der Inhalt
ungefähr jedes dritten Kommentars unter meinen Videos.
Ja, dann mach es doch besser.
Oh nein, ich hasse dieses Argument, Alter.
Dann mach es doch besser.
Das ist wie wenn du sagst, hey, keine Ahnung, bleib mal beim aktuellen Thema, ja, Battlefield
2042 hat eine miese Performance und dann gibt es Leute, die sagen, ja Max, dann programmier
es doch besser.
Das ist doch scheißegal.
Ich hab das Spiel gekauft, ich will das Spiel spielen und das Spiel läuft nicht richtig.
Damit ich sagen kann, dass es scheiße läuft, muss ich das nicht selber besser können.
Diese Logik hab ich noch nie verstanden.
Ja, dann mach es besser.
Das schlimmste Beispiel, was mir einfällt von Leuten, die das wirklich mit voller Überzeugung
argumentiert haben, war und das war so auch der Moment, wo mir damals eingeläuft ist,
dass manche Leute einfach dämlich sind, das war, als ich noch Dark Age of Camelot gespielt
hab und falls jemand auch in den Genuss gekommen ist, das in EU zu spielen, da erinnert sich
vielleicht noch an die Goa-Webseite, das ist der Publisher, der das in EU rausgebracht
hat.
Und die Webseite war einfach nur unterirdisch schlecht, mega beschissen war die Webseite.
So und es gab immer im offiziellen Forum oder auch im halboffiziellen Forum, gab es Rumgeflame
darüber, warum die Webseite so scheiße ist und da hat dann allen Ernstes jemand drunter
geschrieben damals, Leute, beschwert euch nicht über die Webseite, setzt euch hin, lernt
Webdesign, macht eine bessere Webseite und zeigt sie dem Hersteller, sonst ist das doch
überhaupt nicht konstruktiv oder sowas.
Da dachte ich mir so, Alter, Facepalm, wie dumm kann man eigentlich sein, ja und seitdem
fällt mir immer wieder auf, wie dämlich dieses Argument einfach ist.
Ok, weiter geht's.
Besser.
Und ich verstehe, wo das herkommt, Fehler oder Unge-
Ja das ist genau, genauso ist es, Chet.
Das ist wie wenn du ins Restaurant gehst und dein Essen ist was anderes, als du bestellt
hast oder so, oder dein Essen hat noch gefrorene Gurken oder was auch immer drin und du sagst,
Leute, was ist denn das, was habt ihr denn hier gemacht und dann sagt der Koch erstmal,
haha, null, mach's doch besser, das ist so umgefaced das, ja.
Gereimtheiten in einer Sache aufzeigen ist das eine, eine alternative Sache zu schaffen,
die diese Fehler nicht aufweist, das andere.
Trotzdem ist man natürlich auch berechtigt, Kritik an Dingen zu äußern, die man selbst
nicht stemmen könnte, andernfalls wäre Letterboxd die wahrscheinlich größte Sündenmeile
der Welt.
Und dennoch hat sich die EU gedacht, was, wenn doch, und versucht mehrere soziale Netzwerke
aufzubauen, die ihren eigenen Datenschutzbestimmungen gerecht werden.
Vor etwas über einem Monat hieß es plötzlich, die EU würde nach der unendlich langen Liste
an Dingen, die sie an etablierten sozialen Netzwerken auszusetzen hat, tatsächlich selbst
aktiv werden und eigene ins Leben rufen.
Das Problem ist halt, es muss denn irgendjemand verwenden und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass irgendjemand darauf wechseln würde.
Unter den auffällig tiefsinnigen Arbeitstiteln EU-Video und EU-Voice will man mehr oder weniger
YouTube und Twitter nachstellen, aber eben stattdessen mit Datenschutz und finanziert
von öffentlichen Geldern.
Und das kann eine Menge bewegen, sich gegen die Monopolstechnik.
Okay, okay, kann, kann, lass ich, lass ich mir gefallen, wird es aber nicht.
Weil das was dann am Ende rauskommt, ein absoluter Ausgeburt der Hölle ist, die niemand verwenden
will.
Giganten aufzulehnen kann zu einer Verbesserung der gesamten Branche führen.
Entsprechend weit oben waren meine Augenbrauen, als ich das erste Mal von diesem Projekt
las.
EU-Voice basiert auf Mastodon, das die meisten wahrscheinlich von dem ernüchternden Exodus
kennen, nachdem Elon Musk drohte, Twitter zu kaufen.
Mastodon ist ein nicht-kommerzielles, dezentralisiertes Netzwerk, heißt, es gibt mehrere Server,
die eigenverantwortlich von Privatpersonen, Institutionen oder in diesem Fall eben von
der EU verwaltet werden und miteinander interagieren können.
EU-Video basiert währenddessen auf PeerTube, ein ebenfalls nicht-kommerzielles, wie dezentralisiertes
Netzwerk, das zudem noch in Föderationen aufgeteilt ist.
So können sich mehrere Server zu einer Föderation zusammentun, sodass ihre jeweiligen Videos
bei-
Leute, ich sag euch jetzt mal, ich sag euch jetzt mal die Wahrheit.
Hier habt ihr zuallererst gehört, ja, die ultimative Wahrheit, was Social Media angeht.
Die Leute scheißen auf Privatsphäre und auf Datenschutz, das interessiert die meisten
Nutzer überhaupt nicht, das geht denen komplett am Arsch vorbei.
Das sieht man auch an den Antworten auf die üblichen Sachen mit, du hast doch nichts zu
verbergen oder warum sollte ich das machen wollen.
Den meisten Leuten geht das komplett am Arsch vorbei, was Datenschutz und Privatsphäre angeht.
Alles was zählt ist, dass die Leute ein gutes Gefühl dabei haben, den Kram zu benutzen.
Gutes Gefühl bezieht sich jetzt nicht auf Privatsphäre und Datenschutz, sondern eben
auf die Benutzung dieser Plattform, dass es ihnen irgendwie das gibt, was sie auf dieser
Plattform erwarten, sei es auf Twitter irgendwelche Leute, die sich gegenseitig selbst loben können
den ganzen Tag oder sich über irgendwas auskotzen können oder was auch immer, dass es ein gutes
Gefühl beim Benutzen gibt und dass es so einfach ist, dass es auch die Oma bedienen kann.
Das wollen die Leute, das muss easy sein, Datenschutz ist egal, das siehst du bei
Beispielsweise auch schon daran, guckt euch Instant Messenger an.
Du hattest früher sowas wie IRC, IRC war vom Protokoll her das simpelste und einfachste,
was es gibt.
IRC ist im Prinzip, wenn du so willst eigentlich immer noch, der mit Abstand beste Chat und
Chatprotokoll, was es gibt.
Kein XML-Scheiße, kein Jason rumgeschicke, nein einfach stinknormaler Plain Text mit
Kommas und so, kannst du nix dagegen sagen, aber IRC war halt nur was für die Ultrageeks
damals.
So und wenn ihr euch mal Messenger auf dem Handy anguckt, warum hat sich WhatsApp durchgesetzt?
Weil es einfach ist, weil es die Handynummer verwendet, keine extra Nummer, weil es sein
Adressbuch schert, dass dann auch die Oma sieht, wenn der Enkel angemeldet ist oder der Enkel,
wenn die Oma angemeldet ist, die scheißen auf Datenschutz, das ist egal, Hauptsache
das ist einfach und gibt ihnen irgendwie ein gutes Gefühl beim Benutzen, das ist alles.
Die Leute interessiert das nicht, uns interessiert das vielleicht, die meisten User scheißen
drauf, die juckt das gar nichts, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wie die Casual Noobs
damals erzählt haben, oh kennst du schon WhatsApp, kennst du schon WhatsApp, da kannst du, stell
dir vor, da kannst du kostenlos SMS verschicken, da dachte ich mir auch immer, Alter Pains
Champ, das sind keine SMS, das sind Instant Messages, ganz normal übers Internet, wie
alles andere auch, was es schon seit 20 Jahren gibt, aber es war halt easy und WhatsApp hat
es richtig gemacht, sie haben antizipiert, dass die Leute auf Privatsphäre scheißen
würden, weil wir benutzen die offizielle Handynummer und wir scheren Adressbücher und sonst was,
seit 3 Jahren, was ein Nokia 6 5 1 0, sind das nicht so die alten mega fetten Dinger,
ah ne, ok das ist richtig, das ist nicht ganz so alt wie die für die fetten Nokia Dinger,
aber das ist auch schon äußerst oldschool, ja gut da kannst du ja gar kein WhatsApp drauf
benutzen, ob du willst oder nicht, das funktioniert nicht, also ich hab schon ein iPhone, ich
hab ein Handy, was ich WhatsApp drauf verwenden könnte, aber ich verwende kein WhatsApp drauf,
ich hatte, ich überlege gerade mein erstes Handy, das war auch ein Nokia, Nokia C, ne,
wie heißen diese super fetten, ne ne ne, Fett, oder Fett ist jetzt schlecht, groß, alt, alt,
wie hießen diese richtig fetten Dinger, das da, das da, das hatte ich, genau das, dieses
dicke, 5, ok, war das das, genau, dieser, dieser Klotz, das war mein erstes Handy damals,
kann ich mich doch dran erinnern, richtig sick alter, richtig, richtig fetter Klotz war
das, Release Date, 8, da fällt mir wieder auf wie alt ich bin Leute, muss man sich überlegen,
ich war 14, 1998, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen oder, also ich nicht, ich bin im, also wenn
ihr mich fragen würdet, wie alt bist du, würde ich sagen 22, 23 oder so, aber nein
Leute, ich werde dieses Jahr 38, kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, 38, dauert nicht
mehr lang, dann bin ich 40, ist ja schlimm ey, ganz, ganz schlimm, ok, Zack, ok, ich
versuche es, aber jetzt, jeder Aproposن, wir tentang
Meint hast was war das denn noch mal da gab es doch so eine gab es doch nur so eine sache wo die leute zeitlang gesagt haben
Ja max machst du dir auch einen
Dingsbums channel ich habe vergessen wie es heißt
Wo ich immer gesagt habe nee da guckt eh keiner
Dtube ich weiß es nicht ob war das Dtube
Bitschut kann sein ich weiß nicht mal wie das hieß Witmi nee Witmi ist ja ist ist ja down schon wieder
Odyssey odyssey kann sein ja
Ach ich weiß nicht das da sind so viele plattformen entstanden und wieder
Wieder verschwunden die letzten jahre über
Ja weiter diese technologie ist bei weitem nicht unumstritten in anderen peer tube instanzen in denen verfassungsfeindliches material
Veröffentlicht wird gilt man bei einer wiedergabe über peer to peer juristisch auch gleichzeitig als anbieter des inhalts
Das ist schlecht und da wurde ich langsam stutzig das wäre ja bei ausreichender beliebtheit der plattformen eben von
Ebenso wie bei den anderen
Ein auffand den die eu wahrscheinlich nicht über künstliche neuronale netzwerke regeln wird wenn sie diese praxis bei youtube facebook und co. So oft anprangert
Und sowieso müsste dann die eu nicht auch upload dann müsste sich wollte ich gerade sagen da müssten die sich mal mit ihren eigenen gesetzen die sie gemacht haben
Auseinandersetzen und feststellen wie un praktikabel das alles ist die einsetzen weil sie ja nach ihrer eigenen
Verschleißung die sie gemacht haben
Die andere nutzer auf ihrer plattform begehen verantwortlich werden aktuell ist das aber noch kein wirkliches thema die plattformen sind beide schon live
Da kommt doch eh nix gescheif. Oh ja die plattform die sieht aber genauso aus als will ich die unbedingt verwenden. Ja
Aber man kann sich bei ihnen nicht registrieren weswegen ich meine idee dieses video dort als beispiel auch zu verabschieden
Die plattform die sieht aber genauso aus als will ich die unbedingt verwenden ja
Aber man kann sich bei ihnen nicht registrieren
Weswegen ich meine idee dieses video dort als beispiel auch zu verabschieden. Ist das ist das irgendeiner der irgendeinen material design
Template von github runter geladen hat und ist dann für eine video seite verwendet wo es gar nicht richtig passt
Sieht so aus
Veröffentlichen verworfen ab aktuell hat eu voice 20 accounts von den 14 im letzten monat noch aktiv waren und etwa
1500 beiträge
Video hat aktuell 20 videos von den zwei in den letzten 30 tagen veröffentlicht wurden dabei sind einige nicht uninteressante
Also allein schon mit dieser domain kommste nicht weit
tube network europa punkt du wer zum teufel soll denn so was eingeben
53 views das geht ja durch die decke
Das ist ja das explodiert ja nahezu sieben views alter hoi hoi hoi
Da wird youtube aber ganz ganz gehörig jetzt angst bekommen
Aber ganz ganz gehörig jetzt angst bekommen
Im prinzip das was ich mir dachte aber wetten wetten das hat wieder 50 millionen gekostet oder so
Technisch gut gemachte videos aber natürlich auch knapp zwei stündige präsentationen in denen ein beamer bild schief
Abgefilmt wird und so wie es aussieht bleibt dieser umstand auch so denn auch wenn das alles als teil eines so genannten
alternative social media pilot programs bezeichnet wird ist die aufgabe die diese plattform erfüllen sollen war weitem keine vollumfängliche
alternative zu ihren etablierten pontons
Stattdessen werden eu video und eu voice für presse veröffentlichung und
relations durch institutionen der u genutzt und das
Es tut mir leid finde ich äußerst dämlich
Ich verstehe den drang alternative plattformen zu schaffen damit man nicht immer zähne knirschen die technologie nutzt die der eigenen
Vorstellung von datenschutz und privatsphäre eigentlich diametral entgegensteht aber wenn das dazu führt dass
exklusiv für öffentlichkeitsarbeit eine plattform aus dem boden gestampft wird die noch gar keine öffentlichkeit hat ja
Dann senkt sich eine stimmt schon vor allem ist der scheiß wahrscheinlich unglaublich teuer gewesen wieder
Ich meine wir würden sowas wahrscheinlich in zwei tagen machen irgendwie webseite mit 20 videos drauf ja
Aber da hat es bestimmt wieder 50 millionen gekostet augenbrauen schnell wieder in den datenschutzbestimmungen beider plattform spricht man von dem bedürfnis die
usa aus der datenverarbeitung auszuschließen in dem man europäische dienste für die kommunikation nutzt dass man auf werbeeinnahmen und damit auch auf
personalisierte anzeigen durch das auslesen von nutzer daten verzichtet und dass man stets das minimum an daten erhebt das für eine moderne
Funktionalität der dienste notwendig ist alles dinge die vielversprechend klingen aber sich auf eine aufgabe begrenzen dessen sinn
überschaubar ist ich kann es mir nur schwer vorstellen dass eu video und eu voice plattform werden die die normale bevölkerung
frequentiert aufruft wenn sie nicht die möglichkeit hat dort selbst dinge zu bevielzieren ich wein ohne scheiß
dass
dass das wupplos stream archiv ist die deutlich bessere
video plattform
im vergleich zu eu video
Ja und es hat vor allem das bessere die das bessere them ich meine man kann auch seriösere themes machen aber das ist das beste hier
Und weiß dass dort ausschließlich von eu institutionen gepostet wird das wäre ein bisschen wie ein eigenes instagram auf dem
ausschließlich geairbrushed wahlkampfporträts hochgeladen werden
aber ich mag nichts desto trotz den versuch etwas
Bewegung in die sache zu bringen auch wenn sich auf eu video und eu voice auf absehbare zeit nur verschiedene
Behörden gegenseitig für ihre mittelmäßigen pr videos liken und das vermutlich außerhalb dieses kreises kaum jemanden aus der eigentlichen
Zielgruppe wirklich erreichen wird ist es trotzdem ein experiment dass wenn es schon die eu nicht weiterdenkt vielleicht von jemand anderem
Aufgegriffen wird youtube twitter und co aus ihrer unendlichen trägheit zwingt und vielleicht endlich mal wieder etwas neues
innovatives ist das schief auch so was ich glaube schon er loslässt ich finde den gedanken aktuell auch total absurd glaube schon
influencer auf einer von der eu verwalteten
Dezentralisierten video plattform muss man kurz gucken für um gesetze herun gebieselte nahrungsergänzungsmittel machen aber
Hey, es wäre nicht das erste mal dass das internet mich vom gegenteil überzeugt deswegen ich bin mir aber nicht sicher
Hier guckt mal
Twitch klipp archiv archiv back end preischef front end archiv front end hier
Da ist das archiv front end
hog
Ja richtig richtigonic
Also nicht EUtube, das war schief.
So was können wir uns als nächstes angucken?
15 easy home automation ideas, anyone can set up, ok wir machen den Schnelldurchgang,
wir gucken uns einfach hier unten an, time based lights, speaker volume, geolocation,
doorbell ideas, built in sensors, hidden desaster, alles klar, zack, brauchen wir nicht gucken,
oh ne, please, ich hab mich heute schon über new world ausgelassen, es reicht jetzt, spielerzahlen
haben wir auch schon angeguckt, how much fang pays software engineers in 2022, also fang
ist facebook, netflix, google, alphabet, nee, apple, amazon, genau, genau, weil eigentlich
ist es ja alphabet anstatt google, ach geil, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal was software
engineers da bekommen, auf gehts, ja auf, ich will die zahlen haben, zeig her, ob die
wirklich am meisten bezahlen weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ich mein das ist auf jeden
fall eines der prestigeträchtigsten Sachen, wo du als Entwickler gewesen sein kannst,
ob die jetzt wirklich am meisten bezahlen weiß ich gar nicht, ok weiter, facebook, wo
kommt das überhaupt her, also du kriegst im Jahr 122.000 Dollar und davon sind 41.000
Dollar in Aktien oder wie, dann kannst du noch nen bonus kriegen, oder kommt es noch
obendrauf, ach nee das kommt obendrauf, ah also du verdienst irgendwie so 180k, wohlgemerkt
wir sind bei den Amis, ja, da ist das alles immer ein bisschen höher, was ist denn ein
e4 engineer, ok das Video ist mir ein bisschen zu trocken, ok das werden wir wahrscheinlich
nicht werden, aber das ist schon, da kann man sich nicht beschweren als was auch immer
e8 ist, so wie gehts weiter apple, ja wahrscheinlich gibts nur 5 Leute auf der Welt da, die das
kriegen, bei apple reicht es, dass man bei apple ist, so amazon, mich würde interessieren,
was man bei amazon games so bekommt, aha auch ordentlich auf jeden Fall, das ist schon,
das sind schon ordentliche, das sind wirklich ordentliche Hausnummern hier, aber man darf
jetzt auch nicht von ausgehen, dass das da jeder verdient, ja das ist wenn du da in,
was weiß ich, da gibts wahrscheinlich 10 Positionen pro Unternehmen, die das bezahlen
dann oder so, google, google ist auch ordentlich dabei, conclusion, naja gut, also wir wissen
dass wir in oberen Positionen bei google, facebook und so viel Geld verdienen können,
das habe ich mir vorher auch schon gedacht, ob und wie lange netflix da noch dabei ist
ist die Frage, netflix hat ja grad so paar Probleme, was macht eigentlich der netflix
kurs, der ist etwas, ah gut aber es ist alles mega abgekackt, aber netflix wohl irgendwie
besonders, was machen, moment Leute ich muss mal kurz meine stonks gucken, sekunde, sekunde,
wie viel, ob ich nochmal minus 1000 oder so stonks, ich verkaufe den grad eh nicht, ich
warte bis es wieder hoch geht, scalable, so zeig ich mal her, stonks, was machen meine
stonks, denn error has secured, ok ich wurde ausgelockt, super, ich muss mich neu einloggen,
zugangsdaten hier grad nicht, unreal tournament never dies, beste, oh das ist tostmusik, das
kann ich jetzt nicht anmachen, der bitcoin kurs ist auch mega abgekackt, hacking is
samsung galaxy vor 6 millionen dollar, das ist der, wollte ich grad sagen, das ist der
typ mit dem crypto usb stick, das war das letzte mal, wirkte das schon ein wenig gestellt,
keine ahnung ob das wirklich so ist, 14 spiele für die sich die ps5 wirklich lohnt, ok wir
machen den schnelldurchgang, also was für spiele sind das, demon souls, was, sagt mir
gar nichts, final fantasy remake, kann so ein pc ausspielen, aber ich hab ja keinen
bock drauf, astros playroom, das ist doch dieses demo game was dabei war oder, juckt
mich auch nicht, für gta 5 seriously, da muss ich doch keine ps5 holen, last guardian, ok
dafür lohnt sich das, aber das game kam ja schon ursprünglich mal für die ps3 oder
so, alter, geiler job games da, gut gemacht, devil may cry 5 ja meinetwegen, sackboy a
big adventure meinetwegen, grand tourism juckt mich nicht, das wird sich tatsächlich
lohnen, das gab es ja auch schon mit dem ps4, easy, videos im schnelldurchgang, also videos
im schnelldurchgang ohne das video zu gucken, da weiß man bescheid, matte vorlesung an der
uni tria, nee das muss jetzt nicht sein, marode schienen, verspätete züge, verärgernde
passagiere, ich weiß nicht wo das kontrovers ist, das ist so, ich kann die aufmachung
dieser tokus teilweise nicht ab, ok was soll ich mir erzählen, alter ich bin heute irgendwie
nicht gut drauf, ich finde alles kacke, merkt ihr das, 200 frameflicks, wobei ist das nicht
normal, ich finde immer alles kacke oder, boomer, boomer hater, aber wenigstens erzähle
ich euch nicht, dass das früher besser war, meistens ja, stimmt schon, weil war es auch
nicht, so was können wir uns denn sonst angucken, also, 24 dollar destroyed macbook pro, kein
battle field, die call of duty spiele für den ds, lohnt sich das, sanitär, heizungs,
klimatechnik, wie schnell dein geld mit fishing weg ist, wenn man sich dumm anstellt relativ
schnell, ja, ok das gucken wir jetzt, das wird wieder ein absoluter, ok mal gucken,
manchmal machen die ja auch ganz gute Sachen, leider sind die beidräge die wir in letzter
zeit gesehen haben, ein bisschen weit weg von dem was in der überschrift stand, erinnert
euch noch daran dieses irgendwie, susi wird cyberpolizistin, ich weiß nicht wie die hieß,
irgendwie was in der richtung, wo legit nicht eine cybersache in diesem ganzen beidrag vorgekommen
ist, der stuhmorker, dankeschön für den zapp, ok auf gehts, monkaS, 750 p50 fps,
haal lässt grüßen, also der ist doch für das video vorher erst mal die treppe hochgelaufen,
dass er jetzt irgendwie etwas mehr außer puste klingt, oder, aus indien,
ja, wenn man sich blöd anstellt, wer gibt denn übers telefon irgendein random inner tanz
durch, aber gut, aber leute, leute, gut, dass ihr zufälligerweise mit der kamera dabei
wart, wo das passiert ist, haben wir ja nochmal glück gehabt, dass das alles echt so passiert
ist, dann will ich zumindest irgendwie einen film machen aus dieser ganzen misere und ich
war auch sofort schockiert, ok zeig mal her, wie schlimm das da alles ging, sofort war
das geld weg, die banken konnten nichts mehr machen, naja, wenn du ne online überweisung
machst ist das halt weg, und ich hab mich irgendwie gefragt, dürfen die das, dürfen
banken mein geld einfach so schnell weitergeben, natürlich, und so, wenn du ne überweisung
machst, willst du doch eigentlich, dass es überwiesen wird, oder, ok, auf gehts, also
das erste, was einem da schon auffällt, ist, dass da sehr geehrter kunde steht, wenn da
nicht steht, sehr geehrter herr cute chat, dann mach ich mir schon mal gedanken, also
wenn da nicht der echte name steht, oder sei es so der nachname, würde ich schon mal stutzig
werden, ja na na na, ich sag auch nicht, dass ich auf den namen direkt reagieren würde,
aber es ist schon mal verdächtig, wenn nicht der name drin steht, oh ein roter pfeil, excellent,
das erzähl ich jetzt nicht, ich wollt grad was blödes erzählen, aber, wo sind wir denn
hier stehen geblieben, ich hab, ah hier, ich mein die webseite ist immerhin schon mal kein
gebrochenes deutsch und irgendjemand, der schon mal paar setze auf deutsch fehlerfrei
geschrieben hat, hat die erstellt, ein bitt poggers, erzählen, ok, also was ich sagen
wollte ist, ähm, somit, weil irgendjemand gerade geschrieben hat, im zweifelsfall bei
der bank anrufen, bei mir war mal die gez, als ich noch in der alten wohnung gewohnt
habe, als ich meine, als ich meine ausbildung angefangen hab, und da kam irgendein typ und
hat gemeint, sehr geehrter herr max, sie wissen ja sicherlich, dass, ähm, irgendwie wenn
sie jetzt geld verdienen und blablabla, wo ich mir immer gedacht hab, so woher wissen
die das eigentlich, und ich wollte, ich wollte eigentlich, ich wollte eigentlich direkt zumachen,
aber ich hab dann beim message, also ich hab dann geguckt, hab dann geguckt, gefragt wo
kann man dann anrufen, ähm, dann hab ich nachgeguckt, dann hab ich, hab ich dort angerufen,
hab gesagt, ja hier ist ein herr, ich sag jetzt mal, herr müller, der sagt, der ist
vom hessischen rundfunk, ist der wirklich bei ihnen, und da meint, ja der, der ist,
oder nicht vom hessischen rundfunk, doch vom hessischen rundfunk, weil, ist der wirklich
bei ihnen, und da meint der hessische rundfunk, nö, den kennen wir nicht, den kennen wir
nicht, die sagt ja, der sagt, der ist ja von der giz, und dann kam, ja die haben im hessischen
rundfunk nichts zu tun, und warum hat der denn einen ausweis vom hessischen rundfunk,
zumindest, zumindest, ähm, ging das, ging das dann irgendwie, 10 minuten, ob was denn
ist, dann hab ich gesagt, ich red nicht mit ihm, und hab die tür wieder zu gemacht, richtig,
richtig kackspastemäßig von mir, aber ich muss dazu sagen, wir haben damals, ähm, wahrscheinlich
schon mehr gez bezahlt, als, als die meisten, ja, mehrere wohnungen, also, was er von mir
wollte, weiß ich nicht, keine ahnung, ich sehs zumindest nicht ein, ich wollte mit dem
nicht reden, ja, da hat er mal einen ausweis, da stand irgendwas vom hessischen rundfunk
drauf, ich fand's halt, ich fand's halt damals sehr merkwürdig, dass die, sag, gesagt haben,
sind vom hessischen rundfunk, sind gar nicht vom hessischen rundfunk waren, und dass der
wusste, dass ich ne ausbildung angefangen hab, und jetzt geld verdiene, und deswegen
was bezahlen muss, was ja schwachsinnig ist, weil wir damals schon bezahlt haben, und nicht
nur einmal, naja, egal, wir gucken jetzt mal weiter, also, wird weiter gefischt, wo sind
wir stehen geblieben, hier, also zumindest ist es schonmal eine ganz gut gefakte Website,
muss ich sagen, also, da muss man sagen, der Fischer hat sich durchaus, durchaus mühe
gegeben, tja, mit SSL, ja, das ist ja auch kein Problem, das ist ja überhaupt kein Problem,
gültiges SSL-Zertifikat dafür zu bekommen, das ist ja auch, die Domain gehört den Faken
ja wahrscheinlich wirklich, Let's Encrypt, gutes, warum die kaputtes Handy haben, wahrscheinlich,
dass es authentischer wirkt oder so, jetzt ruft der, jetzt ruft der indische Microsoft
Support an und sagt, der ist von der Sparkasse, ist, dies ist Peter, Oldon, sie ist Amerikanerin
und kennt sich mit deutschem Online-Banking nicht aus, und dann steht da damals auch
noch Haspa im Display, wie haben die das hingekriegt, Absender, Absender-Telefonnummer-Faken oder
wie geht das, das ist mir jetzt neu, wie kriege ich, dass es so aussieht, als ist es im Telefonbuch,
obwohl es das nicht ist, kann man irgendwie die Absender-Telefonnummer faken, Haspa im
Display, es war ein Mann, er klang sehr professionell und bestimmt und hat gesagt, dass er von der
Haspa ist und sie machen ein Sicherheits-Update und dafür braucht er einen TAN, er sagt,
das ist immer verdächtig, wenn ich random Leute anrufe und sage, sie brauchen einen
TAN, okay, es war ja nicht random, und ich habe gedacht, ja, ganz einfach, ich kann das
machen und habe ihm einen TAN gegeben, so eine Scheiße, man weiß ja, dass man, ganz ruhig,
das ist aber tatsächlich clever gemacht, oder, ich meine, jemand, der sich da noch nie Gedanken
darüber gemacht hat, er fällt da drauf rein, also, was, also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass die meisten Leute auch so was reinfallen, die sich damit noch nicht näher auseinander
gesetzt haben, ja, das ist doch jetzt, naja, sie hat es ignoriert und sie hat ihn hier
redig verstanden, sie ist halt eben auch keine deutsche Muttersprachlerin und ich bin jetzt,
ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was wir jetzt machen sollen, es ist Freilagabend, ich, keine Ahnung,
Freilagabend, da hat keine fucking Bank mehr aufgeschnitten, aber deswegen haben sie diese
SNS geschickt.
Ein ziemlich ausgeklügelter Plan, der sogar IT-Experte Vincent Haupthardt beeindruckt.
Haupthardt forscht seit Jahren zur Sicherheit von Online-Banking und hat mit spektakulären
Hacking-Angriffen Lücken in Banksystemen aufgedeckt.
Ja, deswegen, am Telefon würde ich nie eine TAN durchgeben, aber jemand, der, also in dem
Fall, verstehe ich schon, warum die darauf reingefallen ist, die hat wahrscheinlich nicht
so die großen Planen von Technik insgesamt, die hat sich noch nie um dieses Angriffsszenario
Gedanken gemacht und wenn die vom deutschen Online-Banking auch keine Ahnung hat, wer
weiß, wenn das woanders funktioniert, ich kann schon nachvollziehen, warum die darauf
reingefallen ist.
Ich meine, ich würde nie Links anklicken, die ich random aufs Handy bekomme, wo drin
steht, ich muss jetzt irgendwas bestätigen.
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass es mittlerweile so ist.
Also mittlerweile sind die meisten Überweisungen ja innerhalb von, weiß nicht wie, das heißt
hier Instant-Überweisungen oder so, mittlerweile geht das relativ zackig mit Überweisungen.
Unter Regel ist es auch direkt weg.
Aber keine Ahnung, ob das ist, wenn es Freitag über das Wochenende geht, das ist eine gute
Frage, ob das am Wochenende noch irgendwo hängt.
Ich meine, es spricht ja eigentlich überhaupt nichts dagegen, dass Überweisungen auch am
Wochenende gehen.
Kein technisch gesehen, aber.
In dem Fall hier war das extrem gut gemacht, also ich fand die ganze SMS auch sehr authentisch,
dass der Absender zum Beispiel Hasbar ist, eine eigene Domain dafür zu registrieren.
Auch fand ich es relativ clever gemacht, dass man diese Verfahren S-Zert genannt hat, weil
das ist die Sicherheitseinheit, wenn man so will, von den Sparkassen.
Und wenn man das jetzt oberflächlich googelt, dann findet man da erst mal was, was durchaus
plausibel klingt.
Also von daher glaube ich schon, dass das aktuell State of the Art ist.
Doch selbst beim State of the Art gibt es ein deutlicher Warnhinweise.
Die SMS.
Banken kommunizieren nie per Kurznachricht.
Die Webseite.
Deutsche Banken haben in der Regel keine.com Adresse und viele der Links führen sogar ins
Lehrer.
Banken kommunizieren nie über Kurznachrichten?
Das stimmt nicht.
Also mal unabhängig von den normalen Sachen mit Einloggen oder sonst was.
Und bei, ich sage jetzt nicht den Namen, aber ich weiß meine Mutter kriegt öfters Nachrichten
von ihrer Bank, von der richtig echten Bank, dass sie sich mal wieder irgendwelche E-Mails
angucken muss im Postfach und Zeug, also das würde ich jetzt so gar nicht unterschreiben.
Was war jetzt an der Webseite?
Banken kommunizieren nie per Kurznachricht.
Die Webseite.
Deutsche Banken haben in der Regel keine.com Adresse und viele der Links führen sogar
in der Webseite.
Naja, also das hätte auch genauso gut eine.de Adresse sein können.
Ich meine, eine Adresse zu registrieren, die irgendwie passt und dann, also ob das jetzt,
das würde ich, das weiß ich nicht, also.
Viele der Links führen sogar ins Lehrer.
Der Anruf nach Tanzfragen echte Bank-Mitarbeiter.
Das stimmt.
Nie.
Also ich würde im Leben keine Tand durchgeben.
Aber immerhin bemerken wir es schon Minuten später, da muss doch noch was zu machen sein.
Mein erster Gedanke, schnell die Notfallnummer anrufen, aber schnell geht hier überhaupt
nichts.
Geben Sie bitte jetzt die achtstellige Bankleitzahl über die Telefonkante ein.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, der war so, die waren so geschockt, dass sie sich gedacht haben,
nehm mal live auf, ich mach dir jetzt einen Fernsehbeitrag zu.
Und dann kann ich das Konto zwar sperren lassen, aber an der Überweisung selbst gibt es nichts
mehr zu rütteln.
Denn sie wurde ja mit unserer Tand bestätigt.
Und wenn dann natürlich das Geld transferiert ist, dann haben Sie bei einer getätigten Überweisung
oft keine Möglichkeit mehr, dieses Geld dann auch zurückzuholen.
Was aber grundsätzlich erfolgt und deswegen war es genau richtig, dass Sie dort auch
angerufen haben, man versucht natürlich trotzdem über Möglichkeiten dann eben einen Rückruf
zu starten.
Aber in der Regel ist es bei einer autorisierten Überweisung einfach zu spät.
In unserer Verzweiflung der nächste versucht das Geld zu retten.
Zum Geldautomaten fahren und das eigene Konto leer räumen.
Hä?
Wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Der Geldautomat bezahlt dir das doch gar nicht mehr aus, das ist doch schon weg.
Hä?
Wir waren jetzt bei der Sparkasse und haben alles was wir konnten abgeholt.
So 1000 Euro, mehr geht nicht an einem Tag.
Das heißt, jetzt ist unsere Hoffnung gewesen, dass man, dass dann das ganze Geld, was wir
auf quasi überwiesen haben, ja dann nicht mehr auf dem Konto ist und nicht mehr... Hä?
... genommen wäre.
Race Conditions, ja.
Die haben nicht schnell genug vom Automat... Wenn das ging, Leute stellt euch mal vor,
dann würdest du dich mit dem Handy, mit Online-Banking vor den Automat stellen, 1000 Euro überweisen
und dann 1000 Euro abheben oder hättest du doppelt 1000 Euro, ganz bestimmt.
Aber ich kann es insofern nachvollziehen, wenn du wirklich Panik hast, machst du komische
Dinge, die nicht wirklich Sinn ergeben.
... aber das ist natürlich, ich hab gerade mit meinem Bruder telefoniert.
Unlimited Money Clips, Sparkassen hassen diesen Trick, genau.
Das ist natürlich ein absolut idiotischer Trugschluss, weil das Geld war ja schon vorher
weg und das einzige, was jetzt passiert ist, wir haben uns jetzt abgehoben und wir sind
dann jetzt mega im Dispo.
Direkt danach fahren wir zur Polizei in Pinneberg und erstatten Anzeige gegen Unbekannt, bekommen
eine Vorgangsnummer und die Information, dass unser Fall an die Cybercrime Unit weitergeleitet
wird.
Ich mein, es wäre natürlich durchaus sinnvoll, wenn die Sparkasse eine, ja, Hacking, wie soll
ich sagen, Hacking, Cybercrime, wie auch immer Notfall-Hotline hätte, wo auch tatsächlich
Menschen erreichbar sind, 24-7.
Also, das wäre ja tatsächlich sinnvoll, ja.
Und es wäre ja vielleicht auch sinnvoll, dass man bei sowas einen Schutzmechanismus
einbaut, den man vielleicht sogar freiwillig aktivieren kann, so nach dem Motto, Überweisungen
gehen nur mit einer Stunde Verzögerung raus.
Das könnte man ja technisch ohne Probleme alles machen.
Ja, haben Sie doch, nee, da war ja aber keiner dran, der Ihnen helfen konnte, da ging es
da aber eben den Anrufbeantworter dran, wo du deinen Konto drüber sperren konntest.
Also, man könnte da durchaus, denke ich, Sicherheitsvorkehrungen treffen, wenn man will, dass das nicht möglich
wäre.
Diese Einheit sitzt in Bad Seegeberg, Monate später bei den Recherchen zu meinem Film
treffe ich hier Robert Nehring, der seit Jahren gegen Kriminelle im Internet ermittelt.
Von ihm erfahre ich, allein in Schleswig-Holstein haben Täter mit vergleichbaren Maschen wie
bei uns in den letzten zwei Jahren mehr als 1,5 Millionen Euro erbeutet.
Sie sollten zumindest nicht darauf vertrauen, dass die Polizei jetzt das Geld für Sie zurückholt.
Also, es ist schon gut, wenn Sie selbst tätig werden und die Banken, von denen Sie zumindest
wissen, selbst kontaktieren, denn bei der Polizei kann das durchaus sein, Sie zeigen
das Ganze jetzt am Freitagnachmittag an, da wird sich ein Ermittler frühestens am Montag
der Sache annehmen.
Wenn überhaupt, wahrscheinlich dauert das drei Wochen, bis sich das irgendjemand anguckt.
Könnte das Geld ja schon alles weg sein.
Also, je schneller die Informationen, desto schneller die Hilfe.
Unser Problem, wir haben beim Anruf bei der Hotline unser Konto gesperrt und damit keinen
Zugriff mehr, können also noch nicht mal nachschauen, an wen das Geld gegangen ist.
Wenn Sie erstmal gar nix haben, dann ist der erste Schritt, dass wir Sie fragen, bei
welcher Bank sind Sie?
Andererseits können wir fragen, da Sie eine SMS bekommen haben, da ist ein Link drin und
dieser Link führt auf eine Domain und diesen Host, da können wir zum Beispiel dann kontaktieren
und fragen, wer hat bei dir denn diesen Web-Space gerade gemietet und wie wird er bezahlt?
Und dann folgt man wieder dem Weg des Geldes, meistens ist der Weg des Geldes die sicherste
Möglichkeit den Tätigsten.
Das klingt durchaus logisch, ja.
Das passiert alles leider nicht am Wochenende, weder bei der Bank, noch beim Webseiten-Hoster,
noch bei der Polizei.
Doch, doch, doch.
Bei Webseiten-Hoster passiert das auch am Wochenende, da könnt ihr sicher sein.
Jeder, jeder Webseiten-Hoster, was heißt Webseiten-Hoster, jeder Hoster oder jeder Cloud-Anbieter oder
was auch immer, der auch nur ernst, ansatzweise ernst zu nehmen ist, hat 24-7 Leute da.
Das passiert da auch am Wochenende.
Bei deutschen Behörden und deutschen Banken mag das nicht am Wochenende passieren.
Bei Hostern garantiert auch am Wochenende.
Die Sache ist halt nur die, wenn du da anrufst beim Hoster, werden die das nicht sperren.
Wenn du da anrufst, werden die das nicht sperren, da muss die Polizei anrufen, das macht die
am Wochenende nicht.
Und ob die überhaupt das sperren, nur weil einer von der Polizei anruft, ist auch fragwürdig.
Aber was ich schon erlebt habe am Wochenende ist, das kann ich euch jetzt ja an der Stelle,
kleine, kleine, kleine Story am Rande, wir hatten mal von irgendeinem, ich glaube irgendein
polnischer Anbieter war das, der hat, ich überleg grad, hat er unser WordPress gehostet
auf der Arbeit?
Ne, ne, wir, also, es wurde versucht ein WordPress, es ist ausgerechnet auf wieder WordPress,
immer WordPress bei sowas, ja, es wurde versucht auf ein WordPress-System von uns zuzugreifen,
die ganze Zeit, und zwar von einer polnischen IP, und wir haben, ich bin mir gar nicht mehr
sicher, wie wir das rausgekriegt haben, wir haben geguckt, eben gehört das, und das gehörte
irgendeinem polnischen Hoster, und die konnten nur polnisch oder gebrochen Englisch.
Ne, nicht die polnischen Switches, das war wieder was anderes, das war irgendein WordPress,
und dann haben die da angerufen, unser, unser 24-7-Support, oder ich nenn's mal nicht Support,
es ist ja eigentlich ein, es ist ja eigentlich ein 24-7-Operation-Center, oder ich weiß gar
nicht, wie man genau das bei uns eigentlich genennt, haben dort angerufen, die haben auch
am Wochenende Leute erreicht, haben gesagt hier, es geht ein Angriff von einem ihrer
Server aus auf andere Systeme, und da haben die sich sofort drum gekümmert.
Also da muss man schon sagen, also da bei Hostern, die da ein bisschen was auf sich
halten, geht das auch mal schneller, also wenn du bei der richtigen Nummer anrufst, je nachdem,
also da muss ich sagen, selbst bei kleinen Klitschen aus, dann hab ich damit eigentlich
ganz gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Dass die jetzt nicht die Domain abschalten, nur weil du da anrufst und sagst, ich wurde
von dieser Domain aus gescampt, das ist klar, und du kannst denen ja viel erzählen, wenn
der Tag lang ist, ja, aber im Falle von irgendwie einem Rechner, der versucht andere Sachen
zu dedossen oder sonst was, das kriegen die ja auch mit, also wenn du es ihnen sagst,
können die das ja auch überprüfen, was da dran ist, also das ging tatsächlich relativ
schnell.
Und die haben das dann auch innerhalb von ein paar Stunden abgeschaltet.
Die Spiegel-Dokumentest-Zentren, nee, ich will jetzt erstmal wissen, was jetzt hier
rauskommt.
Also für morgen, für Samstag, eine Bank gefunden, die einzige Haspa angeblich, Hamburger
Sparkasse, die tatsächlich offen hat an einem Samstag.
Der nächste Morgen, keine 15 Stunden sind seit dem Betrug vergangen, wir haben alles,
was möglich war.
Aber es ist schon schlimm, dass die keine Hotline haben, oder?
Ich finde es wirklich sehr bedenklich, dass die Sparkasse keine Hotline hat, wo du Menschen
erreichen kannst für solche Fälle.
Warum nicht?
Warum gibt es sowas nicht?
Ich meine ernsthaft, das ist ein Riesending und die Sachen sind auch nicht umsonst auf
Freitag Mittag getimed.
Was der Kundenberater am Schalter machen will, naja, vielleicht Leute anrufen, vielleicht
hat er irgendwelche internen Service-Nummern, wo man in Hacker, ich meine ernsthaft, guckt
mal.
Es könnte doch auch durchaus sein, dass irgendein Hacker-Man Freitag Abend irgendeinen
Sparkassen-Server übernimmt und da irgendwelche kriminellen Dinger auf die Homepage schreibt.
Um mich jetzt mal die einfachste Sache zu nennen, ich meine, in Wirklichkeit würde
das wahrscheinlich so machen, dass es sich nicht direkt zu erkennen gibt, sondern versucht
ein paar Sachen abzugreifen.
Da muss es doch auch Leute geben, die dort hingehen und den Gramm ausschalten am Wochenende.
Stellt euch vor, irgendwie der SSH-Zugang zu einem Sparkassen-Webserver ist nicht richtig
gesichert.
Irgendjemand kommt da rein, macht ein fettes Hakenkreuz auf die Sparkassen-Seite, da muss
es doch auch am Wochenende jemand geben, der das wegmacht.
Kann doch nicht sein, dass das 48 Stunden dann ein Hakenkreuz auf der Sparkassen-Seite ist.
Die haben garantiert Leute, aber wahrscheinlich halt nicht für sowas.
Warum kannst du keine Hotline erreichen, wo wirklich du mit jemandem am Wochenende telefonieren
kannst?
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist wirklich, finde ich, bedenklich.
Gehoben, dann unser Konto gesperrt, Anzeige bei der Polizei erstattet und haben keine
Ahnung, ob das hilft.
Aber da muss doch noch was zu machen sein.
Der Typ ab Schalter ist wahrscheinlich planlos.
So, wir haben eine Sparkasse, sieht ziemlich scheiße aus, muss man einfach mal ganz ehrlich
sagen.
Die sagen, die Chancen, dass man das zurückkriegt, sind sehr gering.
Wir wissen jetzt auch die genaue Summe, 3.333 Euro wurden vom Konto abgebucht.
Warum nicht 1,337, okay, das ist weniger, aber.
Und 33 Cent, vielen Dank.
Das heißt also, das ist alle ihr Spartes, das ist wirklich faktisch alles, was da drauf
war.
Moment, die hatten ein Konto, wo 333, nicht schlecht.
Wir haben jetzt allerdings auch die Kontodaten desjenigen, wahrscheinlich ein Fake-Name
von irgendeiner Online-Bank mit einem geklauten Personal, das weiß aber was weiß man nicht.
Alva Anders, na dann.
Vielleicht bringt das was und die können das aber auch nicht sperren.
Die Sparkasse sagt, sie können das nicht sperren.
Der Überweisungsauftrag, also an wen geht das und welche Höhe das ist, das stellt nicht
das Sicherungsverfahren sicher, sondern das müssen Sie, das müssen die Kunden machen.
Wenn jetzt ein Kunde die Transaktionsdetails nicht ordnungsgemäß vergleicht, nicht ordnungsgemäß
kontrolliert, dann gilt das als grob fahrlässig und dementsprechend wäre dann der Kunde in
die Pflicht zu nehmen.
Bedeutet, wir sind selber schuld, weil wir einfach nicht genug aufgepasst haben.
Ja, ist ja auch so.
Ja gut, das ist halt wirklich so.
Es ist natürlich blöd, dass es da keine bessere Unterstützung gibt, dass es da nicht,
ich sage mal Sicherungsmechanismen gibt, die man aktivieren könnte, aber ja, prinzipiell
bist du selber schuld.
Aber immerhin konnten wir den Ermittlern eine E-Bahn und den Namen des Empfängers liefern.
Das muss doch für irgendwas gut sein.
Die wichtigste Information ist die E-Bahn für uns, denn die ist auf jeden Fall echt.
Der Name muss nicht echt sein.
Sie könnten auch einfach Mickey Mouse eintragen, die Bank prüft das nicht unbedingt mehr.
Deswegen ist der Kontoeröffner nicht gleichzusetzen mit dem Empfänger.
Der Name kann wiederum uns aber einen Hinweis darauf geben, ob es woanders im Bundesgebiet
vergleichbare Taten mit demselben Namen gibt.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das Konto, dass es das wirklich gibt und
dass es den Empfänger auch wirklich gibt, dass es irgendjemand ist, der von seinem Glück
gar nichts weiß, auch ein unbeteiligter Typ.
Ja zu Hause rufe ich aus purer Verzweiflung noch mal die Notfall-Hotline an.
Vielleicht helfen ja meine neuen Informationen über den Betrüger.
Geld kann ja eigentlich gar nicht so schnell auf deinem Konto sein.
Wenn man das jetzt ganz schnell irgendwie macht, dann hab ich gedacht, vielleicht hat
man eine Chance.
Wie hat er es denn überwiesen?
Hat er das per Echtzeitüberweisung gemacht?
Wahrscheinlich.
Das weiß ich natürlich nicht so genau, also ich meine, wir wissen schon, was er da getan
hat.
Ach, das steht da auch.
Echtzeitüberweisung, ja.
Ah, okay.
Dann gibt es keine Chance mehr.
Also das heißt, Echtzeitüberweisung heißt tatsächlich, das Geld ist innerhalb von 30
Sekunden.
Ich meine, wenn sowas öfters passiert, und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass solche Scams
wirklich öfters passieren, warum gibt es nicht eine Sicherungsmöglichkeit, dass man
sagt, hey, bitte alle Überweisungen eine Stunde verzögern?
Ich meine, so eine Option, da muss doch schon mal einer dran gedacht haben, oder?
Warum macht man das nicht?
Es soll doch technisch überhaupt kein Problem sein in der Umsetzung.
Die Sicherung kannst du mit der Tanne auch wieder aktivieren.
Ja, da muss man sich halt was anderes überlegen für.
Ja, da gibt es sicherlich Möglichkeiten, dass man das nicht so einfach machen kann.
Das wäre doch tatsächlich eine, da muss irgendwie, man kann garantiert, wenn man technisch
gewillt ist, dort den Riegel vorschieben.
Man könnte zum Beispiel auch gucken, ist die IP, von der sich eingeloggt wird und von
dem die Überweisung ausgeht die gleich, wobei das ist die gleiche, weil die Tannen abgefragt
wurden.
Das hätte in dem Fall nichts gebracht.
Naja, also wenn der Kunde das aktiviert, dann soll er nicht motzen.
Also ich denke, man könnte da durchaus was machen.
Also das dauert eher so 20 bis 30 Sekunden, dann ist das auf dem anderen Konto.
Doch, doch klar.
Warum soll das keinen Sinn machen?
Was mein ich, warum die Leute Paypal verwenden?
Das ist halt schnell da.
Also wenn Sie so direkt fragen, dann kann ich Ihnen auch direkt sagen, ja, das ist ein
gutes Mittel für Betrüger.
Wir als Polizei könnten vielleicht sagen, wir wünschen uns, dass das abgeschaltet wird,
aber da wird ja keiner auf uns hören.
Die andere Seite der Medaille ist, dass Kunden, die in der digitalen Welt leben und auch damit
arbeiten, genau nach diesen Prozessen rufen.
Wie kann es sein, dass eine Online-Überweisung zwei, drei Tage gedauert hat?
Verstehe ich auch.
Und ich will doch, wenn ich online mache, will ich doch, dass das Geld…
Ich will, dass im Zweifelsfall ich das überweise und der andere es direkt sieht und den Kram
los schickt.
Ich will da keine drei Tage warten oder so, was soll das?
Wir sind im Jahr 2022.
Sofort da ist.
Also es ist vielleicht auch ein Stück weit Fluch und Segen zugleich.
Für mich fühlt es sich gerade ganz klar wie ein Fluch an.
Quatsch.
Und den muss ich dir…
Weil nur weil er…
Das ist im Jahr 2022 schon wichtig, dass es so was wie sofort Überweisung gibt.
Ansonsten verwenden die Leute halt Paypal.
Wäre der Typ über Paypal gescampt worden, hätte er nicht mal irgend ein Wort anrufen
können.
Irgendwie brechen.
Mit den Bankdaten des Betrügers recherchiere ich weiter.
So, also, Ivar Andres steht hier jetzt.
Der hat auch eine E-Bahn und eine DIC.
Ich wette mit euch, dass es irgendeinen Typ, der auch gescampt wurde, den gibt's und
der wurde auch gescampt.
Ich gucke jetzt mal, was das für eine Bank ist.
Das ist die GLS-Bank.
Zentrale Service-Nummer, die hat natürlich nicht offen.
Die Zentrale Service-Nummer, Fragen und Antworten hat auch nicht offen.
Karten sperren.
Reachten Sie bitte, dass alle Karten zu Ihrem Konto gesperrt werden.
Weil am Wochenende hier nur Computer zu erreichen sind und ich wirklich verzweifelt bin, fällt
mir nur noch eine letzte Rettung ein.
So hört sich ein Computer an, Leute.
Ich mach das jetzt mal.
Ich lass jetzt mal den Account von dem sperren.
But wouldn't they ask for some information, birthday or something like that?
Wahrscheinlich.
Das ist halt unglaublich, dass es da jetzt halt…
Rechnen Sie bitte jetzt.
Bitte nennen Sie den Namen und die Anschrift des Karteninhabers.
Scheiße.
Anschrift.
Alva Andres, Bahnhofsstraße 3, 2, 5, 4, 2, 1, Pinneberg.
Das ist natürlich klar, ich meine, das wäre ja auch Wahnsinn, wenn wir jetzt einfach…
Aber…
Ihre Kartensperre habe ich weitergeleitet.
Wir müssen jetzt mal…
Ich hab jetzt gerade sein Konto gesperrt anscheinend.
Na ja, mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Wobei, ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das funktioniert.
Irgendwie, was natürlich auch Wahnsinn ist, dass ich sein Konto sperren kann.
Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt irgendwas gebraucht hat.
Ich hoffe, damit habe ich jetzt nicht der Polizei irgendwie reingefuscht, aber zumindest
kann er dann erstmal jetzt nichts machen.
Hoffe ich.
Die Sperr-Hotline, die sperrt im Grundsatz ja keine Konten, sondern die sperrt im Zweifelsfall
nur Bankkarten.
Aber das Konto an sich gegen Verfügung könnte man damit nicht sperren.
Das hätte ich also auch lassen können.
Da ich bei der GLS-Bank aber telefonisch niemanden erreiche, schreibe ich eine E-Mail.
Jetzt sollte da ja eigentlich denen daran gelegen sein, diesen Betrüger aufzuspülen.
Weil die wollen ja eigentlich auch keinen Betrüger bei sich, bei der Bank haben.
Das ist denen wahrscheinlich wurscht.
Was können die machen?
Man kann ganz davon abgesehen, der Typ kann denen ja auch vieles erzählen, wenn der Tag
lang ist.
Also, darauf zu reagieren, das ist halt auch schwierig.
Jetzt für die Bank das nachzuvollziehen.
Ich meine, du kannst viel sagen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Das Geld ist schon weg.
Die GLS-Bank ist eine Direktbank.
Die Kontoeröffnungen funktionieren hier komplett online mit einem digitalen Identifikationsverfahren.
Die GLS macht das nicht selbst, sondern nutzt einen Service der Deutschen Post.
Ein Video-Call, bei dem Ausweisdaten abgefragt und überprüft werden.
Laut Experten ein sehr sicheres Verfahren.
Oder ist beim Betrüger Alvar Andres etwas schief gelaufen?
Ich frage nach bei Christoph Wolf von der GLS-Bank, er hat sich das Identifikationsvideo
von Alvar Andres noch einmal angeschaut.
Also, ich hätte keine Auffälligkeiten festgestellt.
Das Bild auf dem Ausweis, was da war, mit der auftretenden Person, kommt ihm sehr nahe.
Wesentliche Merkmale wie Nase, also Gesichtszüge, Ohrenstellung, Augenstellung, Augenhöhlen,
das war identisch oder nahezu identisch.
Können Sie mir Informationen über diesen Menschen geben?
Leider nicht.
Da laufen zurzeit Ermittlungsverfahren, da kann ich jetzt keine Auskunft zu geben.
Also, einmal schon nicht aus ermittlungstaktischen Gründen, aber auch nicht aufgrund des Bankgeheimnisses.
Irgendwie schade.
Aber vermutlich ohnehin keine echte Spur.
Denn professionelle Betrüger eröffnen die verwendeten Konten eigentlich nie selbst.
Sie können entweder Anzeigen teilen.
Sag ich doch, das ist wahrscheinlich auch irgendein Typ, der gescampt wurde.
... und darüber Leute gewinnen, die das Konto für Sie erstellen, in dem Glauben, etwas
Gutes zu tun, beispielsweise bei einer Marktforschungsumfrage teilzunehmen.
Wie gut eröffnet sich das Konto bei Bank X oder Sie kaufen sowas, beispielsweise auch,
ich nenne es jetzt mal...
Geil.
Five-Fed-Scammer.
Kurz gesagt, das Geld ist immer noch weg und der Täter immer noch unbekannt.
Und als ob das nicht alles schon ärgerlich genug wäre, haben wir noch ein Problem.
Obwohl es eigentlich eher ein Grund zur Freude sein sollte.
Am Montagmorgen um 6 Uhr fliegen wir in den Urlaub.
Zu den Eltern meiner Frau nach Kalifornien, wo wir nur schwer zu erreichen sind, für
GLS Bank, Hasper und die Polizei.
Doch einen Versuch starten wir noch, jetzt wo am Montag alle Büros wieder besetzt sind.
Wir sind jetzt hier in Amsterdam am Flughafen und es ist kurz vor halb neun und ab halb
neun kann ich anrufen bei dieser Hotline und um kurz vor neun ist Boarding.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt genau eine halbe Stunde.
Ja, die Dame der GLS Bank war sehr, sehr nett am Telefon, hat das jetzt alles aufgenommen.
Sie sagte auch ja meistens gefälschte Konten und das haben sie dauernd und sie sagt auch
man fällt dauernd auf sowas rein.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn, da muss man ja irgendwie mal ein System hinter kriegen, wie man das
verhindern kann, oder?
Das denke ich mir auch.
Oder das Wichtigste meiner Meinung nach ist wirklich die Aufklärung der Bevölkerung.
Die Verantwortung.
Du bist selbstverständlich, du bist selbst dafür verantwortlich, ja?
Das Erste ist, lass dich nicht scammen.
Aber ich denke schon, dass man da auch aus Bankssicht was dagegen machen könnte, wenn
man gewillt ist.
Also ich meine, was spricht denn dagegen zum Beispiel, dass man, kann man sofort Überweisung
deaktivieren?
Oder dass man irgendwas, da müsste man halt mal freifertig sich was überlegen.
Ich meine, solche Scams, wenn solche Scams Systeme haben, da sieht man ja, wenn die immer
nach dem gleichen Muster funktionieren, dann sieht man ja worauf die basieren und dann,
dass man sich da irgendwas dagegen ausdenkt.
Kannst du?
Und dieses Misstrauen, dieses grundsätzlich kritisch sein, das können wir als Hasbar
den Kunden nicht nehmen.
Und man muss tatsächlich auch sagen,
Doch, du kannst das schon tracken, aber woher willst du wissen?
Aber woher willst du wissen, ob das jetzt der Kunde ist oder nicht?
Also ich meine, wurde die TAN eingegeben wurde, ja, kannst du, aber du weißt doch nicht,
ob der Kunde, die TAN eingegeben hat oder der Scammer, das kannst du doch nicht wissen.
Ich meine, was du machen kannst, ist, also was du machen kannst, ist sowas, so eine,
so eine, naja, sag mal so eine 70-80% Geschichte, Login und TAN IP unterscheiden sich nicht.
Die haben das Passwort über eine Seite abgefischt, haben sich damit eingeloggt und dann übers
Handy die TAN erfahren, also erfragt, also sprich Login und TAN sind von der gleichen
IP.
Das ist ja der Witz bei dem Scam, nee, nee, nee, das ist die gleiche, Login und Überweisung
ist die gleiche.
Aber was du machen könntest, ist, du könntest zum Beispiel, richtig sowas hier in der Richtung,
das dachte ich mir auch, du könntest zum Beispiel so ein 70-80% Ding machen, wie das beispielsweise
Amazon auch macht oder Paypal macht, so nach dem Motto hier, man guckt, von welcher IP
loggen sich die Leute normalerweise ein und dann machst du einen Geo-Lookup, aus welcher
Region loggen sich die Leute meistens ein und wenn du dich quasi zu, sag mal mal 70%
von einer IP aus dem Großraum Frankfurt am Main einloggst und auf einmal loggst du dich
ein aus Shanghai, dass du dann nochmal eine extra Sicherheitsfrage beantworten musst
zum Beispiel.
Das sind so Sachen, das könnte man durchaus machen und wäre wahrscheinlich auch sinnvoll.
Ja, sowas, ich denke, wenn man gewillt ist da was zu machen, was eigentlich Banken ein
gewisses Interesse haben sollten, sich da auch hervor zu tun versus Paypal und sowas.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem nochmal eine extra Hürde und dass du dann einen VPN kriegst,
dass du dann direkt eine IP aus der Region des eigentlichen Besitzers hast, also so einfach
aus dem Ärmel schüttelst du das auch nicht.
Frankfurt ist jetzt easy, Frankfurt ist easy, Frankfurt hat genug VPN-Anbieter, aber wenn
du irgendeinen Kunde hast, der was weiß ich, aus irgendwie Region, was weiß ich, Niederaffenhausen
oder so sich einloggt und das ungefähr zuordnen kannst, da einen VPN zu finden, wahrscheinlich
nicht so einfach.
Also VPN-IPs kannst du nicht erkennen, VPN-IPs kannst du nur erkennen, wenn VPN-Anbieter
quasi die gleichen Ranges verwenden und du reproduzierbar feststellen kannst, ah, das
ist ein VPN.
Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel du einen VPN aufbaust zu mir, wird das nie jemand erkennen,
dass du da über einen VPN meinen Internetanschluss verwendest oder so.
Also ich denke man könnte durchaus mehr machen, dass solche Scams schwieriger werden.
Und für die Leute, die dir das aufregt, könntest du einfach eine Option einbauen, ja ich möchte
dir das ausschalten und dann schaltest du es halt aus, wenn du es nicht willst, aber
dann darfst du dich auch nicht mal beschweren gescammt zu werden.
Schuld liegt schon auch ein Stück weit bei ihnen jetzt.
Natürlich, natürlich.
Im Film haben wir ausgiebig Zeit über unsere Fehler nachzudenken und uns zu ärgern, über
den Betrüger, die Banken, aber vor allem uns selbst.
Doch dann?
Ja, selbst Schuld.
Wir sind gerade in LA gelandet nach 10 Stunden.
Auf jeden Fall zum großen Teil selbst Schuld dran, aber trotzdem, also, dass nicht wenigstens
meine Hotline erreichbar ist am Wochenende, wobei, war ja anscheinend oder auch nicht?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Stundenflug, ich bin ziemlich fertig und habe gerade eine E-Mail bekommen, dass anscheinend
das Bankkonto gesperrt werden konnte.
Ich kann ihnen aber auch schon sagen, dass wir dem auf die Schliche gekommen sind und
auf die Gelder schon eingefroren haben.
Aha.
Wow.
Der Kunde hat relativ viel versucht, mit Echtzeitüberweisungen zu arbeiten, was sich viele Betrüger zu Nutzen
machen, wo sie innerhalb von drei Sekunden das Geld bei der Empfängerbank europaweit
gut geschrieben wird.
Und dann ist das weg.
Also sie haben keine Chance, das zu stoppen.
Und das ist halt ein Thema, wo unser System merkt, aha, der macht jetzt vielleicht mehr
Echtzeitüberweisungen.
Das ist doch so was, das ist zum Beispiel eine gute Sache.
Du checkst einfach, so nach dem Motto, kein normaler Kunde macht 50 Echtzeitüberweisungen
in 15 Minuten.
Da stimmt doch was nicht.
Das ist üblich, oder auch in anderen Ländern, die nicht so üblich sind, und stoppt die
auch.
Wir können ihnen die 3.333 Euro auch zurück überweisen.
Krass.
Die volle Summe.
Das ist überraschend extrem.
Das ist natürlich für uns hervorragend und da haben wir richtig Glück gehabt und es
gibt wohl noch jemanden, der 8.000 Euro überwiesen hat und der kriegt sie auch zurück.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar Formalitäten erledigen, aber da ist das Geld
wieder da und das ist wahrscheinlich das beste Urlaubsgeschenk, was man irgendwie kriegen
kann.
3.333 Euro und 33 Cent zurück.
Naja.
Eine Achterbahn, eine Achterbahn.
Also, Ende gut, alles gut?
Also, du bist ja nicht von minus 3.000, sondern du bist wieder auf Null.
Aktuell, das hier war ja jetzt quasi, einfach circa 7.000 Euro gerade, was sie gezeigt
haben.
Zurück.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das einen Sinn ergibt, aber okay.
Eine Achterbahn, eine Achterbahn.
Oh Mann ey.
Jetzt kann er sich einfach, jetzt kann er sich nochmal scammen lassen, das Geld ist ja wieder
da.
Also, Ende gut, alles gut?
Nicht ganz.
Monate später bekommen wir einen Brief von der Staatsanwaltschaft.
Das Verfahren gegen Alva Andres wurde eingestellt.
Das wäre mir vollkommen egal, ich hab mein Geld wieder.
Hier steht jetzt nochmal schwarz auf weiß, dass es sich wohl nicht um eine reale Person
handelt.
Also, wo jemand mit einer gefälschten Identität ist, geschaffen ein Bankkonto zu eröffnen.
Das ist bedenklich, genauso bedenklich finde ich, wie gut die Täter einfach organisiert
sind und wie professionell diese Auftritte gefälscht werden und diese Echtzeitüberweisung
macht es ihnen natürlich einen Stürm.
Was daran bedenklich ist, weiß ich auch nicht, weil ich mein, du kannst ja wohl kaum von
Scammers erwarten, dass sie sich dumm anstellen, also wäre gut, ja.
Dürfen Banken, die trotzdem anbieten?
Ja, das dürfen sie.
Klar, warum nicht?
Weil die Kunden da ja ein Stück weit nach verlangen.
Also, du kannst doch nicht alles jetzt irgendwie sperren, nur weil man damit was scammen kann.
In so einer schnelllebigen Zeit, wie wir heute leben, ich persönlich sehe die immer noch
kritisch, aber natürlich haben die eine Berechtigung.
Aber wahrscheinlich können das auch deaktivieren für sein Konto.
Und um das zu stoppen, müssen glaube ich Bankalgorithmen noch besser werden und wir
Kunden müssen natürlich noch aufmerksamer sein.
Es ist gut, dass er das sagt, weil letztendlich musst du selbst gucken, dass du nicht gescampt
wirst.
Um sowas zu verhindern.
Und jetzt interessiert uns natürlich noch eure Meinung.
Seid ihr schon mal auf Phishing reingefallen?
Wie kann man sich schützen?
Was fordert ihr vielleicht auch von den Banken, damit das alles noch sicherer wird?
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare und folgt uns und liked uns.
Ja, das ist keine echte Person, da kann die Polizei wohl nichts machen.
Wobei das nicht unbedingt heißen muss, keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt, aber ich denke nicht,
dass das alles abgebrochen wird, sondern diese eine Sache gegen diese nicht existierte Person.
Dass man als weiter guckt, wer dahinter steckt, das ist ja wieder was anderes.
Kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das passiert.
Auf der anderen Seite, die haben so viel auf dem Tisch, wahrscheinlich sind die froh so
nach dem Motto, ja hat sich erledigt, bam, weg damit.
Das Bildmaterial ist eh zusammengefaked in dem Beitrag, ich glaube da ging es eher um
die eigentliche Aussage und dass man das irgendwie nachstellt.
Also ich glaube nichts von dem Bildmaterial, was man da gesehen hat, war irgendwie wirklich
echt.
Also von diesen, wie schockiert sie waren und so, das war wahrscheinlich alles gefaked.
Weil ganz ehrlich, wenn ich schockiert bin, das letzte was mir einfällt, ist, dass man
meine Handykamera zückt und sagt, nehme ich mal kurz auf dabei, wie ich schockiert bin.
Gut, vielleicht wenn du beim NDR arbeitest, ist es vielleicht so.
Also ich musste mein Scalable Depot auch eröffnen mit PostIdent und dafür musste ich mir sogar
einen temporären neuen Personalausweis holen.
Und nachdem ich in Hanau nicht rangekommen bin, bin ich in eine Nachbargemeinden gegangen
und habe das bei denen gemacht.
Wie das geht nicht?
Wenn da einer durchs Bild läuft?
Ist ja fast wie bei irgendeinem Microsoft-Zertifikat.
Ist natürlich auch sehr sinnvoll, wenn du es dann einfach nochmal machen könntest.
So, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten hier?
MacBook Fix.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal schnell den MacBook Fix in Zeitraffer an.
Das ist ziemlich im Arsch, oder?
Monarch S-USB-Port.
Ohbei, es ist ja kein, es ist ja, nur das hier ist ja USB.
Das hier ist, das hier sind, äh, was sind denn das hier?
Lightning?
Was ist denn das, Chat?
Irgendjemand im Plan?
Ist das, ist das Display-Port?
Mini Display-Port, oder?
Firewire?
Quatsch, das hat doch kein Firewire mehr.
Thunderbolt?
Okay.
Was?
Nein.
Wirklich?
Das ist...
Thunderbolt 2?
Tatsächlich Thunderbolt 2.
Ah.
Alles klar.
Inside this package is a 15-inch Retina MacBook Pro that I paid $24 for plus postage.
This thing, sadly, is in pretty bad condition, and I don't really know if we're going to
be able to get it working, or you...
...or eBay listing.
I'm even possible to test the machine, given that the casing is how...
Das hat aber ordentlich gelitten.
Would you put it?
Seen better days, a one thing that...
Der Audio-Port, man.
...is certain is that the display is a lost cause.
Quite clearly the entire panel is shattered...
Boah.
Also...
Das hat schon ordentlich eingesteckt.
Hat das eine aus dem Fenster geschmissen oder ist mit dem Reifen drüber gefahren oder
so?
...it can be a costly endeavor, but I'd want to make sure that the logic board is at
very least functional before I go and buy any parts.
Despite the horrific shape of the chassis and substantial bend, the main board doesn't appear
to have any corrosion or signs of damage.
To straighten it out, I...
Oder hat sich da ein besonders pepo-fett-Person draufgesetzt?
...I first had to remove it from the warped frame it was attached to.
This required a fair amount of wiggling, and in an undamaged MacBook the board would simply
lift out once the screws were removed.
While the moisture detection stickers had turned red, I couldn't see any signs of corrosion
at all, and no signs of damage either, so I placed the board back in without bending
it back into place.
Now I could plug in the power adapter since the MagSafe jack wasn't obstructed.
Ist da ne SSD drinne, die man ausbauen kann, weil ansonsten würd ich mein altes MacBook
im Leben nicht über eBay verkaufen, wenn da noch ne unverschlüsselte Festplatte drinne
ist, die mit Daten von mir...
...das kommt noch?
Okay.
Oh la la la, das schiebt uns ab.
Fuck.
Oh!
Haha!
Das nächste Schritt war, zu sehen, ob es in einen kompatiblen Installer-USB booten würde.
Um den duschen Port auszuweichen, war das nötig.
Das System hat meine macOS-Installation entdeckt.
Das Trackpad hat sich umgeschaltet und es sieht so aus, als ob die Batterie sogar startete zu schaden.
Nach wem weiß ich, wie lange ich komplett flach sitze.
Um es weiter zu testen, musste ich einen neuen Solid-State-Driven verbinden.
Ich habe mich entschieden, einen aus dem 11-Inch MacBook Air auszuweichen,
den ich seit einiger Zeit benutzt habe.
Dies ist ein Standard M2 NVMe-Driven,
mit einem kostenlosen Adapter verbunden,
welches auch in den MacBook Pro befindet.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, einfach das MacBook-Sofa benutzen,
wer braucht denn schon ein Gehäuse?
Der Boot-Schein hat gespielt und nach einem langen Zeitpunkt
hat es den Apple-Logo gezeigt und in den Operierungssystemen eingeladen.
Die Schläge sahen auch funktionial aus und ich konnte mein Passwort reintun.
Ich habe Probleme mit dem Klicken des Trackpads,
und das ist wahrscheinlich wegen der Bremsen.
Aber wie wir sehen können, ist es ein 2014es Modell mit 16 GB RAM.
Nach einem langen Klicken konnte ich auch die Batterie kontrollieren.
Das Modell ist ein 2014es Modell mit 1.787 Zyklen,
mit ca. 6.000 mAh Abwärtskapazität.
Das ist nicht großartig, aber es funktioniert.
Also, jetzt schauen wir mal, was wir brauchen, um das Modell wieder zu funktionieren.
Nach einem Wort von heute's Sponsor,
das ist der Private Internet Access.
Was haben die gemacht mit diesem Notebook?
Man kann MacBook-Gehäuse kaufen?
Klar, warum nicht?
Na ja, weil da in der Regel ein Notebook dazugehört.
Warum bauen die Leute das aus und verkaufen dann das Gehäuse?
So viel Poggers Bubble Wrap!
Was? Ich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich muss das mal cleanen.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob ich das aufmachen kann, ohne dass es mir auseinanderfällt.
Patrick, du wirst lachen, ich habe mir das Gleiche schon gedacht.
Nicht einfach sinnlos Geld ausgeben.
Das war mein erster Gedanke, ich kaufe ein neues.
Nicht der Fernseher macht Geräusche, die Android TV Box daneben macht Geräusche.
Das ist meistens kein gutes Zeichen dafür.
Warum er noch eins hat?
Er hat sich ein Gehäuse gekauft, oben und unten,
und jetzt hat er sich noch ein neues MacBook gekauft mit Display.
Im Prinzip hat er jetzt 2,5 oder 1,75 MacBooks.
Oder 2,25 eher, weil er hat zwei Boards oder Gehäuse.
Er hat zwei Displays, wovon eins kaputt ist.
Er repariert das Notebook jetzt, indem er sich ein neues Notebook kauft, korrekt.
Moment, eigentlich können wir aufhören das Video zu gucken, weil wir wissen doch jetzt schon was passiert.
Er hat ein neues Gehäuse.
Wobei, Moment.
Er hat doch ein funktionierendes Notebook, was will er eigentlich jetzt?
Ich meine, der will ja wohl kaum den Bildschirm abmachen vom Funktionierenden, oder?
Also wozu?
Dass er aber noch bessere Art für hat, ja?
Das sieht nach irgendeinem Widerstand aus oder?
Oder ne, was ist das? Keine Ahnung.
Kondensator, okay.
Erst mal, erst mal richtig schön Flux drauf spritzen.
Das sieht fast aus als hängt das hier zusammen.
Solar Sucker, genau.
Vor allem, wie hat er das denn hingekriegt, das so zu verkacken?
Ich mein, der hat sogar richtig schön Flux Zeug da drauf gehabt.
Da muss der eigentlich fast nichts machen, außer dran halten und es fließt an die richtige Stelle.
Weißt du, da ist gut, wenn man so ne Druckluftdose hat.
Okay, jetzt hat er schon drei ein Drittel Notebooks daheim.
Okay, nun mal, dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Das hat sich bestimmt gelohnt.
Niemand schraubt sein Notebook auseinander, um die Fans zu cleanen.
Ja, der braucht das kaputte Teil gar nicht, der hätte einfach das neue behalten können, was er noch besser Respekt hatte.
Egal, davor kriegste aber kein YouTube-Video.
Was hat er? Was hat er Applied? Threadlocker? Was soll denn das sein? Schraubenschlosser? Was? Hä?
Eine Schraubensicherung? Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Kleber? Wofür braucht man das? Das ist das, wenn du das Notebook quasi im Auto hast und es vibriert, dass die dich nicht mit der Zeit lösen, oder wie?
Also, wir fassen zusammen, er hat aus einem funktionierenden MacBook, ein funktionierendes MacBook gebaut mit jetzt schlechteren Specks.
Exzellent! Exzellent!
Eine richtige Fivehead-Aktion.
Das war's für heute.
So, was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Okay, schieß los.
Ja, Hauptsache, Hauptsache mal schön in die Nase reingefilmt. Beste Kameraposition immer.
Das war's für heute.